ваші руки не
чують веселіше
[музика]
ти Сіра
житься мо сльози
дівочі
мобутня і сильна назло
ворога
країно до пог всі
мисіні очі тобі своє серце я іки
вя Україно вай Україно іми з тобою на
засти чіти порі Україна не пла бо ззрі
зіти буде щастя і радість мир на землі
є
батінко Люба
тинокостраждала напилася
Лика за доі
ки поліво я тоі що Раду давала і мрію
влекала
[музика]
щасливі
ОІ Україна вставай Україна ставай
Україна тими з тобою назавжди діти твої
Україна не плач свой сльози зіми буде
щастя і радість мир на землі україноста
й Україна іми з тобою назавжди і тільки
твої Україно не плач свой сльз зітрив
буде щастя і
[музика]
радість і мир на землі
мир на нашій
землі буде щастя і
[музика]
радість єдина Земля
піднім руки і вправо
рі
[музика]
з
Слава Україні да
Слава Україна Вставай Україно зімись з
тобою назавжди тіти твої Україна не плач
свої сльози зіт буде щастя і радість ми
на землі Україно
[музика]
в тобою на тільки свої країні нелачво
істоти іки буде щастя і радість мир на
земні країна сама
ми з тобою на завжди івої в країно
неплать звожи зійти буде щастя і
радість і ми на
[музика]
землі Давайте зробимо ва усю щоб це
місто почуло і
[музика]
Дякуємо друзі милюмо вас з вами був дсс
Побачимось
[музика]
ще
один два раз є Мене добре чути
товариство Слава Україні
дніпролава я не чую Слава
Україні
Слава ви неймовірні Слава нації
Україна по ус Україна по усе Україна по
усе дніпряни ви
неймовірні Я радий вас вітати на нашій
патріотичній акції на нашій українській
акції патріоти
єднаймося українці
єднаємося тому що зараз
власне той час коли слова про об'єднання
це не просто
слова це можна вважати закликом до
дії мені надзвичайно приємно бачити
сьогодні так багато людей я маю надію що
нас буде більшати і
більшати будемо зараз з вами знайомитись
Мене звуть Святослав
Бойко Я є волонтером Я є громадським
активістом Я є музикантом лідером гурту
Широкий
Лан бачите багато багато в
одному товариство як я вже казав приємно
бачити вас і ваші
усмішки і особливо в цей карантинний час
приємно бачити усмішки ваші тому що на
багатьох з вас немає масок а Національна
поліція просить вам нагадати що в нас
все-таки ще є карантин і будь ласка не
нехтуйте карантинними заходами вони
уклінно просили вам це нагадати що я
власне і щиро
роблю Я так розумію що нас є багато і
соціальну дистанцію ми дотримати не
зможемо але хоча би Якщо у вас є маска
одягніть її я на себе її одягнути не
можу тому що мені буде важко говорити і
ви не будете мене
бачити товариство Ми пам'ятаємо
під
якими
гаслами під якими знаменами ми боролися
попередні сім
років Це були ті три
стовпи на які повинна опиратися кожна
здорова нація то є
армія як Гарант нашої безпеки то є мова
як засіб ідентифікації і то є Віра Я
думаю не тре треба пояснювати що то є
для нас армія мова і віра але в цей час
оці три стовпи армія мова і віра вони
стали
мішенями ми бачимо як вони стали
мішенями скільки разів звучали вже слова
що от Реванш близько реваншисти йдуть і
так То є правда Реванш близько
і ніхто крім нас не може його
зупинити Ніхто крім нас ніхто крім нас
ніхто крім нас ніхто крім нас ніхто крім
нас
товариство ви напевно вже бачили по
вашому вашому чудовому місці такі
ганебні
бігборди Де написано там різні меседжі і
один з них городу нужен
референдум місту потрібен референдум
і в мене питання до оцих ініціаторів
власне ініціаторами ції інформаційної
ганебної кампанії є опозиційна платформа
за життя опзж Жопа
Просто і у мене до них питання чуваки
який референдум
про який референдум ви можете
говорити Ми всі чудово пам'ятаємо з чого
починалися події в Криму і на
Донбасі так званий референдум і потім
йшли російські танки потім ішли
російські Гради і ми ж не хочемо щоб це
було в Дніпрі тому що Дніпро то є
українське місто чи не
[музика]
так І власне я звертаюсь зараз до наших
шановних
реваншистів Подивіться на себе і
подивіться на
нас ще раз Подивіться на себе і
подивіться на нас і тихцем бочком бочком
відповзайте відповзайте собаки дикі тому
що народний Гнів буде важко стримати і
ви не
втечете ви не втечете тому що з нами є
сила і з нами є
правда і ми в жодному разі не погрожуємо
ні-ні ні ні в жодному разі не погрожуємо
ми ж не хочемо щоб наш який би він не
був Український політиком поповнився ще
черговою когортою потерпілих
правда вони повинні зрозуміти що вони
діють і роблять
неправильно і вони повинні припинити ці
дії і ми їм в цьому
допоможемо в нашого миру любивого народу
отієї миролюбності залишилося от зовсім
зовсім трошки отак на дні трошечки так
що пальцем пошкерпти і буде видно
дно але я вас прошу представники жопи
оцієї опозиційної платформи за життя не
шкрибіть не шкрибіть бо вам гірше від
того буде вам буде від того
гірше товариство на нашій сьогоднішній
акції ви почуєте
слова щирі слова підтримки вам щирі
слова від українців які знають чого
хочуть які знають якою повинна бути
Україна сьогодні з нами є партія
європейська
Солідарність сьогодні з нами є партія
демократична
сокира сьогодні з нами на цій площі і
поій
є громадська кампанія рух Оперу
капітуляції скорочено
рок ви сьогодні почуєте таких спікерів
як Михайло
Забродський Софія фдина Артур Герасимов
Вікторія
Сюмар ви
почуєте звернення від громадської
організації справа громад ви почуєте
звернення до себе послання до
українського народу від громадських
діячів від громадських активістів і ви
сьогодні матимете нагоду почути класну
музику власне Вже вже ви чули чудовий
місцевий колектив чудову команду дер До
речі ще раз ваші Оплески їм вони цього
заслуговують сьогодні ми будемо
працювати з хлопцями з широкого лану
Вони зараз на ю обладнання налаштовують
апаратуру і в кінці нашого
заходу будуть виступати справжні такі
перці української сцени справжні козаки
гурт козак System
ще в 14-му році
Дніпро місто Дніпро велика славетна
козацька столиця стала отим
центром
опору
окупації саме Дніпро був отією твердиною
на яку ми
волонтери опиралися на яку
опиралися
добровольці військовослужбовці збройних
сил України та інших військових
формувань всі ми чудово знали у
будь-якій ситуації якщо щось не так їь у
Дніпро там підтримають і допоможуть
дніпряни І за це вам великавелика
дяка І сьогодні ми бачимо як московські
прихвостні оці воші вони лізуть зі своїм
референдумом я не буду добирати слів до
них тому що якщо щось виглядає як
смердить як То може це і є
і я ще раз
наголошую
щокраїн Дніпро ніколи не стане
трикольоровим тому що за оцим
біло-голубим кольором який йде за
опозиційною платформою за життя
ховається Триколор це є оті реваншисти
які тягнуть за собою
Росію це є оті реваншисти які тягнуть за
собою русский мир бачите їм захотілось
референдума і не побоюсь того слова того
виразу що
єдинадина політична
сила яка протистоїть зараз оцим
московським бошам і гнидам то є
європейська
Солідарність яка направила до
прокуратури звернення стосовно
неправомірності дій представників
Московської
жопи
і
ми можемо сказати тільки одне що
референдум в Дніпрі може бути тільки
один дьоготь або пір'я в чому обваляти
оцих клоунів московських і гнати сраною
мітлою до
кацапії Ми ніколи не ми можемо ми можемо
сумніватись у виборі зброї але ми ніколи
не будемо сумніватися у який бік
стріляти тому що ми знаємо що хто є
нашим ворогом нашим ворогом є Росія і
тільки ми ми здатні втримати нашу
Україну тому що нам не потрібна чергова
ДНР нам потрібна українська Україна ми
не допустимо жодного реваншу ми не
допустимо жодного
референдуму і зараз
товариство прошу вашої уваги на
екрани європейська
Солідарність проти референдуму увага на
екрани я народилась виросла в Дніпрі я
чітко пам'ятаю як лішили прапор Росії
під обласною державною адміністрацію в
місті Дніпрі тоді молодь тоді активісти
волонтери тоді наші партійці вийшли з
Протестом і чітко сказали Ні
окупанту сьогодні ми бачимо що за
допомогою зеленої влади за допомогою
теперішнього президента який став по
суті подушкою для проросійського реваншу
знову повторюється те ж саме на бордах у
місті
Дніпрі пишуть про референдум Ми добре
пам'ятаємо чим закінчився референдум в
Донецьку в Луганську та в Криму Дніпро -
це Славне патріотичне місто яке зупинило
русскую весну наша фракція в 2015 році
міською раді перша проголосувала і
визнала Росію країноюагресором Дніпро -
це Фарпост нашої держави нашої славної
України і ми не дамо його розпитати
скажемо сепаратизму ні
[музика]
тих самих депутатів що пропонують
проводити якісь референдуми в Дніпрі є
нічим іншим як злочином причому
державного масштабу варто пригадати що
фактично власником партії опзж є Віктор
Медведчук
удіона людина кум Володимира Путіна який
завжди виступав з вердвета про
російських позицій і не приховується
Навіть зараз ми бачимо спроби
реалізувати Тут те що
сталося в частині Донецької області
Луганської області та в українському
Криму коли проросійська п'ята колона
і Кремль
намагаються провести тут так звані
референдуми з яких ми пам'ятаємо що і як
розпочалося на окупованій території
України ці референдуми не несуть нічого
окрім розрухи смертей І занеподу
територі тому ми зробимо все для того
щоб тут жодного Шансу у цієї історії не
буде А для цього Я закликаю всі по
[музика]
що ж товариство мені тут додати нічого
мені справді додати
нічого знаєте є
така така фраза інколи гуляє вона Влітку
зазвичай що Дніпро
позеленів Дніпро позеленів це означає що
річка Дніпро
зацвіла просто ріка Дніпро зацвіла і
ніяке інше значення в ці слова Ми
вкладати не можемо і не
будемо
І ми з вами чудово знаємо що Дніпро не
те що не позеленіє він не стане ні
трикольоровим
Ні
біло-голубим він буде
[музика]
жовто-блакитним І
зараз зазвичай
таке роблять інші ведучі коли оголошують
там гурт власне Я зараз матиму таку у
честь оголосити самого
себе оголосити наш гурт Широкий Лан ми
приїхали до
вас з нашою програмою з нашими піснями з
тими піснями які підтримують солдатів на
фронті з тими піснями які підтримують
бойовий дух
українців з тими піснями які несуть
правду з тими піснями які говорять про
пра
з тими піснями які дають
[музика]
віру
покищо сюди щоб не в кадр бо
[музика]
воно
ало я набираю полювого ми відійшли
на
можулетіти
Давай Да Да Да Вона стоїть біля
[музика]
менеключаєте саму
її все виставляй Вікторію в
[музика]
кадр будь
ласка Ура
Ми не
ратуємо
срми
карями і немаємо
ої
[музика]
долі Візьміть трубку просто слухайте
ви
Ало Да чую
вас дуже погано вас чути
дуже я
[музика]
шукаюєві
я
чути нас тому що тут у нас дуже голосно
тут дуже багато людей сьогодні зібралося
і це в принципі я думаю достатньо
показова історія коли місто Дніпро яке в
14-му році справді стало форпостом
захисту України сьогодні говорить якраз
ні ніяким референдумом які нав'язує тут
опозиційна платформа за життя і Ну ми
знаємо зараз які тенденції відбуваються
сьогодні в українській політиці про те
що слуги народу збираються робити в
місцевих радах коаліції саме з опзж з
Власне кажучи політичною силою Віктора
медведчука і дуже прикметно що саме
Дніпро сьогодні першим говорить ні таким
коаліціям бо такі коаліції означають
розворот курсу і очевидно місто яке
знаєціну в яка знає ціну зрештою захист
України яке знає скільки коштував захист
України воно сьогодні готово сказати що
патріоти мають об'єднатися для того щоб
не було розвороту України від Європи
назад в русский
мир
ви знаєте от дуже хороша реакція
патріотичних ткіл Тому що тут не тільки
європейська Солідарність тут дуже багато
різних громадських організацій тут дуже
багато знакових людей які воювали на
російсько-українській війні тут багато
інших політичних сил патріотичних
політичних сил і всі вони будуть
сьогодні виступати тут і всі вони будуть
говорити одне якщо не об'єднаються
патріоти то об'єднаються їхні вороги і
ми цього допустити не
[музика]
можемо все дякую Вже
зникну дякую вам дуже погано чути Але я
думаю що ви могли за мікрофон Я думаю
воно було чути Нормально Да ви ще ж
будете було чути да картинка була Ок
нормально Ви ж будете тучи А ми тоді для
сюжету підпишемо вас як стрім закінчимо
дякую вам
[музика]
дуже
дю наступта пісня Це
наш теперішній сучасний погляд на
отамана
Сірка ви пам'ятаєте що він не програв
Жодної битви і
Козаки ще см років ходили походи і несли
його руку і не програли жодного
разу власне оте справжнє козацтво ота
Наша історія це те що повинно жити ти
нас це те що повинно
давати силу це те що повинно давати
знання те що повинно давати Віру ми не
просто так тут живемо тому що в нас були
славні предки славні пращури Які Для нас
це право
[музика]
вибороли одаман
Зірко
[музика]
не
Іна у ій подобві
тварина
нуя коцена машина
[музика]
мий син самого
сина
о дому
[музика]
наши
прийде ча
[музика]
істане віпасе горизонт і тримає
облогу і викликає
ітому
[музика]
щоо тобі брат нетихомий
фармат поїдач снігури в
кривалика о
Тама Зірко то було чи не було
[музика]
загулола
знову
приде
часкиста
нас
[музика]
ходи по воі Ів на
броні і міг завалити і навіть у сні
ліблювати котів на уі
береги наі пальці правої лівої
руки о нава Зірко то було чи не було
ка
[музика]
сагула знову
прийде час
[музика]
нінело не було
до знову прийдечас
ки
[музика]
на
за слову козацтва отоман рко
[музика]
дякує
наступна
пісня Вона буде в
присвяту одному з наймолодших кіборгів
святославу горбенку на псевдо
скельт який
загинув 3 жовтня при обороні старого
терміналу Донецького
[музика]
аеропорту таке Інколи буває коли є
технічні
[музика]
неполадки
Ну що ж будемо працювати без акустичної
гітари самі обставини кажуть що так
треба головне бути
гнучким 13-й
воїн
[музика]
всю весну
закосяли
Бог і я ї проживу за
двох твій останній патрон відірвав рзон
і прибв літну смугу до неба так
треба так
треба не
буває чужих
[музика]
могив на
витоні твої сліди
теі наще стоїть перший рівень горить і
зір заникнувся від Диму і то
[музика]
вашко ти стояв до кіця
дуі бреткі кликали люю
чи знав ти коли що Насте
ідитиступиш і станеш героєм
неся
івою
вам Небесний
[музика]
компас
середилотопа і
розда
проненині на бої крила нести милий брат
ти на завжди солдат з
тобою Така твоя
[музика]
доля доісни
кора на
томниста і селими ти за ліброю сотні
роки імати на дотета
Неви 13й бої
[музика]
тистояроіся духи предків кликали до бою
чи знати коли що на стежку ти
нетиступиш і станеш
героєм 13-й воїн
ти стояв до кінця
[музика]
духи предків кликали добою
чи знав ти колись що на стежку віни ти
ступиш і станем
героє
13тий
воїн 13тий
воїн 13й
поїн Герої не вмирають Герої не вмирають
Герої не вмирають Герої не вмирають
Герої не вмирають Герої не вмира
гроям
Слава Бачу що нас стає все більше і
більше товариства підходьте ближче не
соромтесь Зберігайте соціальну дистанцію
одягайте масочки підходьте
ближче власне наступна пісня Вона буде
дуже такою
символічною вірш до тієї пісні Був
написаний більш як 25 років тому му
Оксаною
забушко живим класиком яку вже треба
вивчати в школі в 14-му
році просто неймовірний чудовий колектив
сестри Тельнюк поставив цей вірш на
музику і буквально Минулого року ми з
товариством широким ланом запропонували
сестрам тельюк таку кооперацію і ми цю
пісню заспівали і зіграли разом
Сьогодні на жаль ми без сестричок тут
будемо обходити своїми силами тим не
менш ця пісня Хай стане лозунгом і
символом для кожного з
нас А ви нам
[музика]
допомагайте
разом з
[музика]
Дніпро і
таки хвали в Бога за голодам ніхто не
служив дарували від батька дочина частю
сдок яки Буки мої бреки були красиві
ворога насдили
Хай Славою Бог сам з нею Я з пристагою
кашабля мої рехки владали землею і ми
навежала Ця земля й не Славою побть тамм
з нею як присягою наша ля мої яси
владали землею їм належалася земля ітути
в нашви доснови крізвіки однієї зім'ї
невразжливи пронесли слово і вни зали в
легені бої Поки моцна булага порота
соловти магада полила мої реки були
народо
Вою з нею Я з присягою нашаля
ї реки
лазелею
іменалежала Ця земля Хай не
заватою з нею як присягою нашаля
килися
ілежала
[музика]
земля Дніпро разом зі
мною і Співаємо
разом Хай де Славою Бог та з нею я
присягою наша
ї реки владали землею ім належалаця
земля хайде свою А з нею Я присягую
нашапля мої ки владали землею їм
належала Ця земля їм належала Ця земля
їм нали залоця земля їм нали залоця
земля їм нали залоя земля їм нале залотя
земля їм нале залотя земля їм нале
залота земля ім нале заолота
земля Слава Україні
славаїні
[музика]
Дякуємо ну і зараз на короткий час я
мушу попрощати зі своїми музикантами і
сказати їм хлопці чекайте за сценою тому
що в нас буде ще друга частина друга
черга нашої музичної частини
і ми в кінці нашого
першого такого блоку Ми недурно цю пісню
зіграли останньою Чому тому що зараз
мова піде про Як ви думаєте про
кого хто відстоював нашу землю хто
відстоює нашу
землю
армія армія наша
легендарна
армія
ви
знаєте дивлячись на
теперішні події в
Білорусії можна зробити один висновок
можна 30 років
мовчати можна забути про свою мову можна
забути про свій прапор про свою
національну гідність забути що таке
єдність але це не поможе тому що рано чи
пізно на твою землю прийде іх там
нет і він буде калічити твоїх дітей він
буде калічити і бити твоїх жінок він
буде вбивати
чоловіків вони не зупиняться Ні перед
чим вони не мають якогось природнього
стримку абсолютно
і ви пам'ятаєте якою була армія 14 році
Ви добре пам'ятаєте Я знаю що хто Хто А
Дніпро добре пам'ятає якою була армія
тому що через Дніпро йшли
ешелони через Дніпро пройшло дуже багато
військових і власне нашою гордістю
українською гордістю є те що ми змогли
підняти оту армію як би то банально не
звучало але підняти її з
колін
одягнути взути нагоду
але нова армія - це не
тільки новий одяг це не тільки
бронежилети це не тільки
казки це не тільки нове озброєння це і
нові сенси нові смисли нова ідеологія
яка відриває нас від
Совка кожен крок який ми робимо і робили
від Росії від Совка він ся дуже і дуже
тяжко ви то чудово знаєте і
пам'ятаєте але ми змогли це зробити Ми
змогли це зробити змогли підняти свою
армію змогли допомогти їй і
армія за нас відстояла і власне оті
хлопці і дівчата які тримають небо над
Україною над нашими головами То є наша
гордість і
хто Хто А ми мусимо забезпечити їм
надійний
тил і згадуючи про нові сенси про нові
смисли я попрошу вас зараз звернути свою
увагу на екрани та буде просто чудова
відеоробота про нашу нову українську
армію і там прозвучить марш нової армії
увага на
[музика]
екраних
ли
великої голини пожеж війни і полуя воми
лита нас бі залою України зстив нас Гнів
і рух на ворогів ливав нас біль за долю
України пров нас нів ідуть на
ворогів
[музика]
Ми йдемо бі переможним ходом радіі сїн
не зламні україн бо плач не дав нікому
ще
Свободи говорець той зоуває свій болаш
не дав нікому ще Свободи
хборез той слує сві Україну Україна ста
патеро сята патеро віти досмо всіти до
сермо за за твою славу за твої святітей
за твої святітей
Неш не ш
[музика]
сла
посе
посе велику суть для усіх єди наш гордий
Клич народові несе вічизні буть
вірний бе зупину нам
Україна вище по на все
чині ірний безуну на Україна
Ще
[музика]
по
Слава Україні геро Слава Слава
[музика]
Україні от переглядаючи це відео мене
Чесно кажучи переповнює радість і
гордість і зараз з нейменшою гордістю і
радістю я цю сцену запрошую легендарного
командира героя
України народного депутата України від
європейської
солідарності людину яка просто не на
словах знає що таке честь і гідність яка
знає що таке боротьба за незалежність
яка знає ціну цієї
Незалежності
зустрічайте Михайло завродський
[музика]
шановні
однодумці Дуже дякую всім і відношу
традиційно відношу ваші Оплески не на
свій персональний рахунок А на рахунок
наших славних збройних сил і всіх
силових структур які смий рік
поспіль нашу
[музика]
землюяякуєякуєякуємо
сятуємо
[музика]
сятуємо дятуємо
якуємо
[музика]
якуємо Я впевнений що ці слова вдячності
і це Дякую чують не лише в Дніпрі а
дякуючи нашим засобам масової інформації
в тому числі і на лінії зіткнення і вони
теж вам дякують повірте мені Дякую за
підтримку і за те що пам'ятаєте яку
важливу функцію вони там виконують Тема
нашої сьогоднішньої зустрічі
єднання чимало слів сказано стосовно
того як це важливо згадували Ми сьогодні
і нашу історію і в історії теж можна
згадати чимало моментів коли єднання
було вирішальним фактором для того щоб
історія здійснила свой черговий
поворот більше тисяч років тому в тому
числі і на цієї землі єднання не було в
Київській Русі князівство які
суперничали між собою не змогли
об'єднатися і Орда проковтнула їх всіх
загнавши більше ніж на 300 років в
рабство трохи пізніше років 500 тому
назад в козацькій державі не було
єднання
її теж поглинула Польща і
Росія на початку
сторіччя коли вперше в новітній історії
у наших
відчизників був історичний шанс
побудувати незалежну державу теж не
вистачило єднання і вже інши орди
большовійські прийшли надовго прийшли на
довгі 70 років на цю землю і ось
наступив 91й і незалежність яка
дісталась нам просто
дісталася одного часу ми пишалися що в
нас не було крові як в Прибалтиці у нас
не було війни як на Кавказі ми 23 роки
жили як незалежна держава 23 роки
Керманич розповідали нам про
многовекторность про те що навколо одні
друзі про те що надо терміново позбутися
чної
авіації ракет і ще багато чого щоб
красть знадобилася в 14-му році і ось
навесні 14го вперше нашу незалежність і
наш вибір і наше право жити так як ми з
вами хочемо Ми були вимушено відстоювати
зі
зброєю наші збройні сили добровольче
формування Національна гвардія
підрозділи МВС здивували всіх в першу
чергу наших противників тому що ніхто не
чекав такого опіру І такої активності в
другу чергу саміх себе тому що ми як
ніхто знали з чого ми починали і див
ніхто не очікував і в третю чергу
Відповідно ми здивували весь світ ми
українська нація тому що така хвиля
підтримки яка була народжена в далекому
14-му вона не входила ніякі розрахунки
ніякого Генерального штабу Російської
Федерації
це і волонтери це і ті хто опікувався
пораненими ті хтодавав останню копійку
на те щоб все-таки вистачало
бронежилетів і було пальне і були
боєприпаси це ті хто І поруч і зараз з
нашою армією
хто і зараз переймається проблемами які
в ній
існують але в цей же самий час тут в
глибокому тилу і навіть в нашому з вами
рідному місті жила інша сила Та яка
відносить себе до річників і прибічників
тих дякуючи яким і почався і Майдан і
всі події 14-го Рока Я веду мову про так
звану опозиційну платформу тоді вона
носила іншу назву і с років Вони
просиділи тихо Як Миша під
віником але десь близько року тому вони
знов почали рахувати що їхній Час
прийшов І зараз на жаль при певному
сприянні в тому числі і діючої Влади
вони відкрито виходять на вулиці не
соромлячись говорять про новий вибір і
нові перспективи навіть в стінах
української Верховної ради І знову
кличать нас туди
туди те в те що вони називають руким
миром і добре б ящо наскликали з вами
світ Пушкіна тургеньва Ні вони кликають
нас в інший світ вони кликують в той
світ де через півпланети ходять
авіаносці застарілих конструкцій лякаючи
всіх вони кличуть нас в той світ де
можна безкарно бомбардувати Сирію вони
кличуть нас в той світ де можна влазити
в українські справи і намагатися
звернути нас з нашого шляху в той світ
де за пост в Фейсбуці можна отримати
реальний термін
ув'язнення ось яхній світ їхня
перспектива Ми говоримо Ні ця
перспектива не наша Я теж би дуже хотів
щоби Дніпро і Павлоград продовжували
робити ракети але я хочу щоб люди яких
роблять ходили на роботу і їздили на
роботу по європейському місту
європейської державі а не так як це
робиться у Північного
сусідов коли пів країни мають Вибачте
мене удобства на вулиці зато ракет
більше чим у всього світу в месті взято
разом
взято ми говоримо про єднання єднання -
це наша відповідь тим викликам які
з'явилися саме зараз саме на етапі
місцевих виборів жодна політична сила
навіть не приховує що місцеві вибори -
це платформа це основа для майбутніх
парламентських А може навіть і
президентських Тому зараз наша
послідовна позиція і наше єднання
єднання саме патріотів єднання яке не
зобов'язує один одного до чогось єднання
рідних політичних сил без жодних
поступок власною ідеологію без жодних
оборудок єднання на основі єдиної
платформи якою є політична сила партія
європейська Солідарність політична сила
яка за рік роботи в парламенті нічим
себе не запятнала до якої не може бути
жодних звинувачень і жодних претензій ні
в якихось політичних оборудках не в
догорняках не в недотримані своєї
позиції наш шлях визначений ми йдемо по
му по ньому і йдемо
разом рухаємось разом і далі покажем им
в ЧМ тут разница дякую
[музика]
ще і ще ваші обласки Михайлу
забродському Він вартий
того ви знаєте я я пам'ятаю
Я пам'ятаю пана Михайла коли він був ще
командувачим десантно-штурмовими
військами і я як музикант приїжджав на
Схід до військових і була така нагода
коли сам командувач сидів при тих
концертах і за дуже велику за дуже
велику удачу уважалося те що пан Михайло
посміхається під час концерту зараз він
посміхається Навіть трошки частіше але
тоді Було це це було дуже велика удача
що пан Михайло посміхнувся
і мені казали все Ти прийнятий в
сім'ю і він говорив справді важливі
речі нам не пробачать що ми їм
дали по зубах в 14му році і продовжуємо
давати до цих
пір Повірте то така гідра що їй рубаєш
одну голову а виростає
дві але ми і на ту гідру знайдемо своє
рішення
Я знаю що
вони цілковито і остаточно об Україну
зламають
зуби почалось на Донбасі і на Донбасі
закінчиться цей Донбас повинен бути наш
то є українська
земля і ніяка Перепрошую жопа тобто
опозиційна платформа за життя не буде
диктувати свої правила чи не так
[музика]
і зараз на цю сцену Я запрошую народного
депутата України співголову фракції
європейської солідарності у Верховній
Раді України Артура
[музика]
Герасимова Вітаю вас
[оплески]
Дніпро приємно і важливо бачити сьогодні
на цій площі стільки людей стільки
соратників яким небайдужа доля нашої
держави Дякую вам за
це також хотів би передати всім хто
сьогодні на цій площі щирі вітання від
лідера української опозиції незламного
державника Петра Порошенка
але
сьогодні на жаль держава знову у
небезпеці у небезпеці через
Реванш Кремля і проросійської п'ятої
колони в нашій державі у небезпеці через
повну
непрофесійність нинішньої влади яка
свіідомо чи Несвідомо дрощіть і ламає
все що ми з вами Потам і кров'ю
створювали протягом цих нелегких пяти
років
але хочу всім подякувати бо в 14-му році
саме Дніпро саме ваша область стала тим
форпостом який не дозволив ворогу
просунутися далі по території України
і Я впевнений що і сьогодні в році 20-му
Дніпро стане тим
форпостом який не дозволить цьому
реваншу захопити нашу Землю вбивати
наших людей і лишати майбутнього лишати
без майбутнього наших дітей саме тому
сьогодні коли держава під такою загрозою
всі патріотичні сили всі кому Україна
важлива всі кому Україна не байдужа
спина до спини мають стояти у цій
давайте бути відвертими війні за наше
майбутнє війні за майбутнє наших родин і
дітей від європейської солідарності можу
вам гарантувати що ми зробимо все для
того щоб захи ти кожного українця
захистити фундаментальні цінності нашої
держави захистити нашу армію захистити
нашу мову захистити нашу віру і
захистити реальне життя кожного
українця
але ми могутні тільки тоді коли всі ми
об'єднуємося тому ще
раз
колеги всі кому Україна небайдужа маємо
об'єднатися і разом йти до перемоги
європейська Солідарність як потужна
опозиційна проукраїнська проєвропейська
сила готова до цього робить це і
обов'язково переможе в цій боротьбі Бо
Україна
важлива а
з
незалежністю не жартують слава
україніг
слава ми всі добре знаємо
що під час бойових дій коли хтось з
наших залишається пораненим у сірій зоні
його йдуть
виручати як мінімум так було до
недавнішнього
часу один
разючий просто кричущий
випадок
він зламав Моє
уявлення
про про те як можна діяти
разом чесно кажучи мені важко зараз
підібрати слова ви
пам'ятаєте історію Коли наш розвідник
Ярослав жравель чотири дні пролежав у
полі Він чекав на допомогу чекав на
підтримку і він її на жаль Не дочекався
4чотири
дні 4отири дні за чотири дні можна світ
Звернути за чотири дні можна обірвати
всі телефони світу за дні можна зробити
дуже і дуже багато але було не зроблено
абсолютно
нічого і сьогодні з нами
є неймовірно мужній і сильний чоловік
якому є Що вам
сказати я одного разу вже чув його
виступ І я не міг його ніяк
коментувати Я хочу щоб ви почули його
зараз
Я запрошую на цю сцену батька загиблого
розвідника Ярослава
жоробля Сергій журовель ваші
[оплески]
[музика]
Оплески Слава
Україні Слава дорогі мої земляки
дніпропетровці
хто-небудь з вас знає чому сьогодні
такий добрий прохолодний
якщо ви не знаєте я вам скажу подивіться
в небо і ви
побачите Соколів Холодного Яру зараз в
Новомосковську остання гусениця сходи на
землю 93 бригада Холодний Яр повернулася
додому сотні жінок сотні дітей сьогодні
обнімуть батьків матері не будуть чекати
дінка а побачать своїх
синів
хочу ще сказати вам на
мені Мені вже дуже важко розмовляти Ну
от на мені Футболка морідноси це
футболка взводу розвідки 20-го окремого
мотопіхотного батальйону 93 бре це
футболка того взводу де люди жили одним
кулако одним пальцем одним духом де
ніхто нікого не зраджував
Де кожен ішов за кожним як вовча зграя
слабший йшов спереду середній по центру
сильний заді такий Це був дві людини з
цього зводу загинули Ну вони перевелися
в другий звод другий
батальйон один трагічно загинув
підірвався розвідник Дмитро
краснор коли
Пішли його евакуювати вино ну всі проце
знаєте був поранений
міс так от я хочу
сказати зараз Вся Україна взнала правду
Ну коли
керівництво 35-ї окремої бригади
морської піхоти приїхав до мене в двір
додому я жив в Малому селі Андріївка
навих у дніпровсь
і ніхто не сказав що вас там дорогенькі
чи в горіви чи в радості буде знімать
хтось цього ніхто не сказав ходила жінка
в темному десь із-за углів щось
знімала розказали вони брехню саму
натуральну брехню
факт в тому що Ну тоді ще не було
записів колі естоні вчора мені
телефонувала його
наречена Я їхав з Києва і вона мені
телефонувала
Я бачив
двох один загинув а з другим Я вчора
спілкувався двох самих настоящих
морських піхотинців України це загиблий
естонець Коля Елі і Андрій підлісний
який вчора
виписавсязо ну зараз Я трошки відволікся
зараз не про І от бригада приїхалана
розказувала І вся Україна це все оці
уривочки
дивляться а потім ми узнаємо що це сама
настоящ
брехня починаючи от комбата і
закінчується командуючим морською
піхотою України Сама настояща брехня
брехня Не зупинилась брехня
продовжується пан Зеленський приїжджає
на передову приїжджав розташування 35-ї
бригади морської піхоти Із рук в руки
моментально вручає орден замужність
третьої ступені бійцю розвіднику
якого видно на відео як він тікає бросає
товаришів губи оті магазини з автомата
подарувавши їх сепаратистам ОІ 60
патронів і йому вручають нагороду Невже
Володя не розуміє що його просто
окружили ота і держуть за дурачка що
тикнули в руки тому він і ради оце все
що я хочу сказати
Ну я думаю
народ
України ну постави крапку оцьому всьому
оцій брехні Винні будуть наказані не
будуть наказані Ну як то чи відсторонені
чи я я не хочу щоб моя смерть мого сина
просто так промайнула а отам на
веркодніпровщині могила журавля Ярослава
ні так не повинно так не повинно бути
повинна бути правда оце сам Головне що я
хочу сказати А перед тим як Ну от я
виїжджав з ркодніпровщини
сюда так щоб всі знали от те що тут в
серці я їхав сам я знав про це я даже не
не знав про отакий великий рухли ну
скільки буде народа но я їхав своїм
серцем своєю душою я других поглядів був
другої політичної сили я ж цього не
скриваю ну коли мені мій живий син
сказав що па Ти ж своїми очима бачив
коли в сандалях вискакували зимою із
Танків і в тебе просили хоть бутинки
хоть валянки Куди ти тулися так я просто
зрозумів просто зрозумів що мій син був
правий тому я приїхав сюди щоб
піддержати європейську Солідарність
просто я кажу не для кіна не для чигось
піару люди добрі я кажу правду Я приїхав
своїм ро і своїм серцем те що в мене тут
що було в мого сина я вам сказав Слава
Україні Слава
[музика]
робира робира
ро Дякую за правду і за вашу
сміливість зараз Я запрошую на цю сцену
народного депутата України від
європейської солідарності Вікторію
[музика]
Сюмар Слава
Україні Слава дороге моє Дніпро Я
народилася на
Дніпропетровщині я страшенно цим пишаюся
і я зараз врно пишаюся що я стою поруч
із батьком справжнього героя України з
паном Сергієм
жиравлем я лише народний депутат я лише
політик і це ніщо порівняно з кожним
українським героєм який сьогодні захищає
Україну бо вони
герої па Сергій сьогодні говоривдужега
важливих речей як не має бути і ми всі з
вами знаємо Не має бути так що Україна
не захищає своїх захисників і воїнів так
не має бути не має бути і ми маємо зараз
сказати Ні капітуляції ні капітуляції ні
капітуляції ні
капітуляції ні капітуляції ні
капітуляції ні капітуляції так не має
бути так не має бути що українську армію
сьогодні відводять із позицій які
завойовані людськими життями так не має
бути бо це політика
капітуляції так не має бути коли Юрій
коли пан Ярослав журавель досі і його
батько Сергій
журавель не визнані сьогодні на
державному рівні героями України бо це
деморалізує Ярослав журавель - це герой
України журавель герой журавель герой
журавель - герой журавель- герой
журавель герой журавель герой журабе
герой Я дуже хочу
зараз із вас висловив свою
позицію і сказав так що ми всі хто
зібрався тут ми за те аби Ярославу
журавлю посмертно На жаль оце його не
поверли присвоїли звання герою України
Так
герою так герою так герою так героїв так
героюв так героїв і ми цього доб'ємося
рано чи пізно бо справжні Герої і Ви це
вже сказали вони не вмирають давайте
згадаємо їх хвилиною
мовчання
пане Сергію я хочу сказати вам моє серце
сьогодні з вами я бачила те відео багато
разів моє серце сьогодні з усіма тими
батьками і мате ми які втратили на цій
страшній війні своїх дітей і з їхніми
дітьми які втратили своїх батьків ми всі
хочемо щоби це припинилося і я
знаю ніхто нас не зламає ми в цій війні
переможемо Донбас - це Україна Крим - це
Україна Україна - це нація переможців
Слава Україні
[музика]
слава
Слава
украї
[музика]
Слава
Україні
[музика]
тут прозвучали такі слова
що ми не маємо права забувати тих хто
пішов від нас в
бою і справді якщо отак на хвилинку
просто
уявімо що оці реваншистські сили Вони
отримують зелене світло і вони починають
качати референдум тут що це буде
означати особисто для мене то буде
означати що вся наша
робота з кінця 13го року тобто починаючи
від
Майдану починаючи від
російсько-української війни окупація
Криму окупація Донбасу вся наша робота
вся наша боротьба були
марними Ми не маємо права забути чину
загиблих наших військових
ні добровольців ні бійців збройних сил
України ні Національної гвардії ні сил
поліції тому що кожен хто поклав своє
життя він віддав найбільшу
жертву і тільки
єднаючись тільки єднаючись ми досягнемо
свого тому що разом сила разом сила
разом
Дніпро разом сила
разо сила разо сила разо сила Я запрошую
на цю сцену народного депутата України
восьмого скликання політичного та
громадського діяча Максима куришва ваші
[музика]
обласки
дорогі
друзі
побратими ситуація в країні
вимагає загальнонаціональної
мобілізації всіх
проукраїнських всіх
демократичних всіх патріотичних сил яку
кому болить за долю нашої
державу ми
єднаємося ми єднаємося Заради
перемоги
перемоги над кризою державному
управлінні перемогою над безладом і
хаосом в країні ми єднаємося Заради
перемоги над катастрофою в економіці
України ми
єднаємося над перемогою заради по
боротьби хамства влади по відношенню до
людей І
зараз я хочу
звернутися до
них
ці зелені
жебенята прагнуть перетворити Україну в
болото але в них нічого не вийде тому що
з кожним днем наша сила
зростає з кожним днем люди все більше
прокидаються від навіданих відосиків
дурмана про так званих слуг народу до
них
звертаюсь ви не слуги
ви
мародери ви
безбатчинки ми вас звільняємо з на вихід
все на вихід з на
вихід на
вихід
на на друзі А зараз я до вас
звертаюсь Давайте скажено так щоб на
почерських пагорбах в Києві почули і
Кривий
Ріг і кам'янське і Павлоград і
васильківку і намосковськ і синельника і
весь наш потужний Дніпро з на
вихід на вихід все на вихід все на
вихід на вихід
друзі нас попереду чекає дуже велика
робота Так нам не буде
легко але чтко і всім з впевненістю
скажу ми обов'язково переможемо І зараз
я хочу вам нагадати 14й і 15й рік коли
ми всім народом об'єдналися і з нуля
створили армію коли ми всі об'єдналися і
захистили державний
суверенітет ми тоді
вистояли вистли Отже перемогли і
сьогодні всі наші здобутки ця Влада хоче
спаплюжити і
зруйнувати децентралізація
це та реформа коли кожен громадянин
України кожен українець кожна громада
відчула на собі і мільйони людей
побачили як почали відновлюватися їх
територіальні громади наповнюватись
місцеві бюджети розвиватися ін
і сьогодні ця зелена жаба лізе в кишеню
до наших місцевих
громад їм це не
вдасться тому що ми знаємо як це
зупинити ви знаєте як це зупинити і
сьогодні Дніпро має
об'єднатися Дніпропетровська область має
об'єднатися країна має об ти Слава
Україні
[музика]
сла запрошую до слова керівника фракції
європейської солідарності у Дніпровській
міській раді Каміль
Примаков шановні патріоти шановні
волонтери шановні мешканці нашої
дпропетровщини Слава
Україні Слава три тижні тому в нашому
місті з'явились борди з написом Дніпру
потрібен якийсь там місцевий референдум
Ми пам'ятаємо з вами що такі референдуми
проходили В 14-му році в Луганську в
Донецьку та в Криму і чим це закінчилося
це війна це розруха і це ізоляція від
всього світу Також ми з вами м'ятаємо що
в 2014 році саме Дніпро перший
відправляв волонтерів на фронт що в 2014
році саме Дніпро приймав перших
поранених а також на жаль і перших
загиблих героїв тому я вважаю що це
п'ята колона Кремля хоче розхитати наше
патріотичне місто тому я як голова
фракції європейської солідарності
міської ради зверну
до керівництва СБУ Дніпропетровській
області щоб вони дали правову оцінку цим
закликам цим бордам і цьому референдуму
Дніпро - це Флагман нашої держави Дніпро
зупинив російську агресію Дніпро зупинив
русскую весну тому зараз я хочу сказати
сепаратизму Ні зараз я хочу сказати що
патріоти мають
єднатися зараз я хочу сказати що Дніпру
потрібна єдина українська патріотична
сила слава
україніва Ми бачимо що з такими
представниками місцевої влади які
буквально миттєво реагують на такі
сепаратистські
заклики все-таки майбутнє у нас є
майбутнє є
І власне гасло гасло нашої сьогоднішньої
акції Українці єднаємося це не просто
так це не просто так і це не просто
гасло це не просто слова це заклик до
дії я вже це говорив і буду я не
втомлюсь це повторювати
і я знаю що є ще одна людина яка хоче
вам сказати своє слово депутат
Дніпропетровської обласної ради від
європейської солідарності Гліб
[музика]
Пригунов Доброго вечора Дніпро Доброго
вечора
сячеславщина дорогі земляки шановні
однодумці Я впевнений що ми тут з вами
однієї думки Тому що тут зібрались ті
люди які однаково ставляться
до Незалежності України до унітарності
нашої держави які мають одну думку про
те якою повинна бути Україна сильною
незалежною квітучою головне вільною і
самостійною І сьогодні ми всі з вами
пам'ятаємо як в 2003 році починалась
помаранчева революція і в четвертому
вона продовжилась багато сьогодні
знайомих облич з якими ми починали
європейський Майдан на європейській
площі у 13-му році ми з вами пам'ятаємо
як в 14-му році ми стали на заваді отих
хороводів з триколором навколо оперного
театру
ми з вами пам'ятаємо як в 15му в 16му
роках у маршрутках у Дніпрі були такі
пам'ятки як впізнати
сепаратиста Ми дали відпір російської
агресії Дніпро зупинив руський мир але
сьогодні ми знову
бачимо провокації ми знову відчуваємо як
насувається політичний Реванш політичний
Реванш від
опзж політичний Реванш від домовленостей
між зеленою владою і опзж і сьогодні я
хочу подякувати народним депутатам від
європейської солідарності які
представляють не тільки Дніпро які
представляють Львів Київ інші регіони
нашої держави які приїхали сьогодні в
Дніпро щоб сказати Ні місцевим
референдумом і нас не може ніхто там
обвинувачувати в тому що референдуму
вони є вони потрібні так Це
найвища ступінь
демократії де референдум потрібен але
той який передбачен в Конституції той
який передбачен
законодавством місцеві референдуми не
потрібні сьогодні вони загрожують
незалежності нашої держави і я сьогодні
Дякую всім хто має розум сили
об'єднатись навколо єдиної дієвої
опозиційної партії якою є європейська
Солідарність я хочу подякувати
громадським активістам які
почали писати заяви в в поліцію
національну про порушення законодавства
на отих бордах про референдум я хочу
подякувати фракції європейської
солідарності яку я маю
честь бути в неї в обласній раді що ми
звернулись до керівництва правоохоронних
органів щоби припинити заклики до
сепаратизму Я ще раз хочу подякувати
всім вам за те що сьогодні ми разом І
сьогодні ми разом кажемо ні сепаратизму
ні для тих хто не розуміє державну мову
Я хочу сказати що Дніпру
референдум не нужен слава украині Героям
слава і слава Дніпру
с я тут можу хіба додати що хто не
розуміє української мови ви знаєте гасло
чемодан вокзал
Росія тому що українець повинен розуміти
українську мову А хто не розуміє чи не
хоче розуміти будь ласка чемодан вокзал
[музика]
Росія як я вже говорив що ці хлопці і
дівчинка вони ще повернуться на сцену
вони власне і
повернулись наступна пісня власне яка
зараз
прозвучить вона перекладена вірси
перекладений більш як на 100 145 мов
світу на початку X
століття пісню яка була зроблена з цього
вірша співали як гімн
України і ми
зробили Своє бачення цієї пісні іде мова
про тарасівський заповіт Заповіт Тараса
Григоровича
Шевченка Хай ця пісня
дає наснагу на боротьбу вам конкретно
вам не якимось тим українцям а конкретно
[музика]
вам
рук та
поховайте мене на
мотилі серед степу
широкого на Україні милі щоб вони широко
порлі і Дніпро і кручі Було видно було
чути я
[музика]
ребечить
я
[музика]
реба як понесе з
України
усиняєбоже кров порожу о тобі я і лани
готи все покину і
полину до самого
тога А до
[музика]
того я не знаю
Бога я
незналюбо
[музика]
повайтевайтедате і врадую звою
кров'ю
люіка і мене сімї
великий сімї
воїно не забудте
[музика]
пом'янути нелив лю
слово нею лю
[музика]
слово
А зараз буквально на мить заблющить очі
і Уявіть собі оті сади оті ліси оті гори
отой Дніпро поріг
[музика]
гревучий Сокола над Карпатами і спів
солов'я в
лузі і це є це ота Україна ота омріяна
оспівана
Україна в нас немає двох чи трьох україн
в нас вона тільки
одна I не мамо wa
їїти мумо
зубамиг iр їла
ворога тільки разом тільки єдності Серце
до серця і плече до
[музика]
плеча покавайте та
вставайте кахайдани
порвіте і вражую злою кров'ю волю
окрапіть і мене сім'ї
великій сім'ї волі новій не забудьте
[музика]
пом'янути не звим тиним
словом
нем
[музика]
слово
[оплески]
українці разом плече до
плеча рука до руки Серце до серця з
Україною в
[музика]
серці
Дякуєм Дякуєм
Дніпро
[музика]
вітер холодний Північний поближ на
горані
жрами сонце подуже у небі піднялось
Високо над нами
Ми вперед мийдемо Перед
добувати
[музика]
soner
buyu
вірний
є по
же бу
[музика]
переікоє кожна спіла що зкитає пране
ворото крові
ми
доходу готові
[музика]
ми
Mu
[музика]
рітом
поремиє ідуть
па
тадурогу
да і коже з нас тихе життя за виною
лишає
стопаі виступає
[музика]
йде
я
мийдея
[музика]
Так слухаю
вас Дякую
дякує
Нати що дані могами ще хочуть нашиого
неба
ми як завди мо іднесми
приносімореву
а завтра ми вдари нарано як гро і стане
іною відброюй
ризні
росяво ворожою
Вю
Мия
[музика]
мий
Вітаю вас з українського
Дніпра
[музика]
ви знаєте сьогодні більше 3 000 дніпрян
більше 3
000 найкращих представників
Дніпропетровської області зібралися тут
на цій площі перед обласною
адміністрацією щоб висловити свою чітку
підтримку тому що Дніпро є Україна тому
тому що наша областьє
і ключове чому це сьогодні виникає тому
що на жаль сьогодні
через непрофесійність нинішньої влади
через недолугість багатьох її дій Реванш
Кремля і Реванш п'ятої колони стає не
просто чимось на сторінках підручника чи
чимось ефмерним А стає реальним і як ви
знаєте тут в Дніпрі була спроба
агітувати і підготувати так званий
місцевий Дніпровський референдум ми всі
пам'ятаємо що сталося після так званих
референдумів в Донецьку в Луганську в
українському Криму І сьогодні люди
вийшли сюди на площу в центрі міста щоб
висловити своє рішуче Ні сепаратизму щоб
висловити свою рішучу
підтримку Україні і щоб підтримати
фундаментальні основи української
держави європейська Солідарність це
реальна опозиційна
проукраїнська проєвропейська сила яка
чітко пообіцяла сьогодні і дріплянам і
ви знаєте ми робимо це по всій Україні
пообіцяла те що ми зробимо все від нас
належне для того щоб не були зруйньовані
ті фундаментальні цінності і основи
Української держави які дозволели
Намри агресію які дозволили нам значно
просунутися у нашому спротиві ворогу за
п років це підтримка української армії
це є підтримка нашої мови і підтримка
нашої церпи але ви знаєте сьогодні ще
дуже приємно що на цю площі на заклик
європейської солідарності прийшли
представники дуже багатьох демократичних
політичних партій дуже багатьох
демократичних громадських організацій і
вони теж підтримують це об'єднан
[музика]
я вам щиро дякую вам щро
дякую йде у
серце гє ге
гєге рге
рге
сяди
поле більше не ведеш до
мати срітло іде
[музика]
по
дякує іди маро дом іди маро ністом Іди
маро куди хочеш тільки не залишайся тут
і ми цю Мару проживемо
обов'язково Тому що ми знаємо ціну нашої
Перемоги ми знаємо ціну нашої свободи і
ми знаємо що Двічі не вмирати якщо
воювати то з музикою якщо воювати то з
гонором нехай так і
[музика]
буде
д
[музика]
лий
користувати
[музика]
славити
ажевачи
про неляли
й хлопці зні
чи Рома вижи не
убирати дейно лоі розброї
гуляти в
герецілиграбати дали по мармати
же бачи
віі невеляти
гйлоки
зброї аши па про
ди не
вбира гй
лоці
[музика]
розброй
на поможе святи Юр дай Пречиста бати
лико свою
Пати
ащелачи пропав ще не обмиране
[музика]
йновосьі розброї
ши Маши
пробов не вмирати
[музика]
йі розро
е
[музика]
he
Дякуємо Дніпро дві
[музика]
немидати Ну і що ж ми проважаємо
музикантів зі сцени а я знову з вами
залишаюся я вам ще не надоїв Ні всеце
добре це тішить з вами власне був ГУР
Широкий Лан з міста столиці з міста
Києва
Я завжди це після концертів наших кажу
що гурт з вами не прощається гурт вам
каже до зустрічі до побачення Тому що ми
обов'язково з вами ще колись та й
Побачимось рано чи пізно при тих чи при
інших обставинах
сьогодні бачите Які
обставини собаки декі хочуть референдуму
А ми цього не
хочемо тому що нормальна людина здоровий
українець
знає чим пахне референдум від жопи від
опозиційної платформи за життя від
кацавських прихвоснів від московських
вошей ми знаємо чим Це пахне ми знаємо
чим це може закінчитись і ми ж цього не
хочемо
правда не хочемо ну
власне оце бажання чистої України нас
сьогодні вивело на цю
площу І недарма
ми закінчили свій музичний виступ на
козацькій
тематиці тому що я
хочу сказати Одну таку давнюдавню
українську приказку
що мовляв детри де два українці там три
гетьмани Якщо вам хтось таке каже можете
сміло плюнути в очі і сказати що то дощ
падає Чому Тому що де один українець там
вжеє вся Україна де українці там вже
реальний двіж де три українці там
Московському окупанту є
смерть і ми свого доб'ємося рано чи
пізно ми свого доб'ємося тому що ми не
зійдемо з нашого шляху з наміченого
шляху і зараз в цей справді складний
час довкола ідеї українства
єднаються партії єднаються громадські
рухи громадські
кампанії навколо цієї ідеї приходять і
витають українські митці музиканти тому
що це ідея здорового українця оця ідея
чистої України вільної незалежної це
ідея здорового українця і так Воно
повинно бути і сьогодні на нашій акції
як я вже говорив на початку є також
представники тих політичних партій та
громадських кампаній які нас підтримують
у нашому єдиному пориві до очищення
України до визволення України до
вигнання оцієї Московської нечесті і
Московського непотребу геть звідси І
зараз на цю сцену Я хочу
запросити
очільника політичної партії демократична
сокира у місті Дніпро Віталія
кальницького
[музика]
Доброго дня
друзі і слава Україні
сть років потому Україна довела усьому
світу що вона незалежна і цивілізована
країна
сть років тому український народ силою
вигнав звідсі того хто хотів зробити з
нас московських кріпаків потім довелося
боронити нашу Батьківщину і наші
військові до сьогодні дуже впевнено
втримують одну з най більших армій цього
світу і так дають по зубах що
огого також на чно полі було здобуто
багато перемог весь світ весь світ
пятьшсть років тому дізнався що є така
держава Україна є незалежна нація є
міцна
нація весь світ дізнався що є міцна
нація Але серед нашої нації чомусь в це
повірили не усі Чомусь так сталося що ми
дали можливість людам людям повірити у
брехню брехня лилася ну з
усіля брехня лилася на людей і
73% цьому
повірили і
зараз ми на межі
капітуляції Але чи вірите Ви що в нашій
країні 73
мріють стати кацапськими кріпаками
скажіть мені так чи ні
то я думаю що ми не маємо дати
можливість оманути наших людей ще раз ми
повинні
об'єднатися
сьогодні тут присутньо багато
партій ліберальна демократична сакира
бірсцентриська європей Солідарність є
рух опору капітуляції до котрого входть
дуже багато проукраїнських активістів і
громадських діячів з міста Дніпра і
області Так ми маємо на певні питання
різне бачення Але у нас є одне бачення
щодо нашої батьківщини ми маємо
проєвропейський Вектор ми маємо бути в
колі цивілізованих країн а не
кріпаками України котра сама є в себе
кріпаками тож ми маємо об'єднатися
об'єднатися стати міцними рядами тісними
рядами і йти до Європи і вести за собою
усіх наших громадян і я вам обіцяю вже
наступні вибори покажуть що якщо ми
об'єднаємося Якщо ми підемо
разом 70 3% буде нас а не тої зеленої
потвори тої гиедоти і сорому нашої
країни тому я призиваю вссіх
об'єднуємося навколо України навколо
європейського вектору навколо руху до
цивілізованого світу до НАТО
ми за цивілізацію ми проти
кріпацства
Слава Україні
друзі Дякую вам і ще дуже приємно було
чути завжди Тому і сьогодні попрошу вас
злюе
[музика]
злю Дякую друзі Ви самі
найкращі зашую до слова координатора
руху опору капітуляції у місті Дніпро та
області Андрія
денисенка Слава
Україні Слава
Нації шановні друзі Я надзвичайно радий
сьогодні бачити так багато сильних
свідомих патріотичних українців
представників різних політичних сил хто
сьогодні прийшов сказати так об'єднання
українських патріотів і рішуче ні
референдумом і будь-яким іншим проявам
сепаратизму в Дніпрі в серці України Я
вам дякую за це шановні друзі за те що
нас сьогодні так багато за те що тут
представлений не тільки Дніпро а й всі
райони і міста нашої рідної
свячеславщини шановні друзі ми з вами
вже багато місяців виходимо на
майдан наших міст ми творимо великий
потужний
проєвропейський рух опору і не тільки
рух опору капітуляції до якого я маю
честь належати але й рух на захід рух до
джерел до європейської української
України
саме це має об'єднати
патріотів наше об'єднання має носити не
лишень передвиборчий характер хоча
надзвичайно важливо завдати поразки
режиму цієї зеленої плісневи прямо в її
лігю на жаль Дніпро - це не лишень серце
України не лишень батька добробатів і
міста патріотів
Дніпро став оплотом тимчасово
через обман який приніс Зеленський
Коломойський і вся їхня Зелена банда
через той розворот через ту зраду
України яку здійснив Коломойський що в
14-му році спільно з нами З вами сидів в
адміністрації захищав Україну На жаль ми
знову як прибрежнві батьківщина застою А
зараз ми Батьківщина зелени і плісняви
тим більша відповідальність лежить на
всіх нас на дніпрянах на ячеславцях на
мешканцях нашої області у нас
геостратегічно важливий регіон ми це
довели в 14му році коли не дали Путіну
побудувати велику
новоросію від Харкова до Одеси коли
знищили цю пітлю якої намагалися цю
удавку задушити Україну і ніхто я вам
скажу шановні друзі Ніхто не завадить
нам дати під зад капнякам зеленському
коломойському всім цим капітулянтам
колаборантам зрадникам України і
надзвичайно важливо щоб європейська
Солідарність інші політичні сили які
підуть на вибори і представлені сьогодні
тут провели чистку своїх рядів щоби не
допустити в жодному разі перевертнів
зрадників колаборантів ряди українських
сил які підуть на вибори мають бути
чистими як
ніколи не має бути сумнівів в репутації
представників місцевих рад
територіальних громад які прийдуть до
влади під патріотичними і державницькими
гаслами і прапорами такі люди в
дійсності є вони є серед вас Вони є на
цьому Майдані вони є в партійних
організаціях серед громадських
активістів волонтерів і
добровольців шановні друзі
припиніть будь
ласка Я вас прошу припиніть будь ласка
ходіння Майте повагу шановні
друзі
Я хочу сказати і ніщо мене не завадить
ні на цій сцені ні в цьому місті ні в
цій країні в
цілому я доведу свою мову до
кінця Ми повинні дати відсіч всій
Зеленій гідрі цій плісняві яке нищить
Україну гасла про сепаратистський
референдум так званий Дніпровський
референдум які з'явилися на білбордах на
вулицях Дніпра Це прямий наслідок
зради яку Зеленський і його компанія
веде по відношенню до українських
національних
інтересів це могло з'явитися тільки в
регіоні де владу очолюють люди
Коломойського
справа в обласній раді засідає Олійник
смотрящий від Коломойського зліва в
обласній державній адміністрації засідає
ставленик Олійника шістка Олійника і
Коломойського Бондаренко Саме ці люди
несуть пряму відповідальність за те що в
2014 році в Донецьку і Луганську як в
14му році в Криму на дніпровських
вулицях з'явився якийсь незрозумілий
Дніпровський референдум і є стільки ки
одна відповідь щодо можливої участі в
цьому референдумі це якщо на нього
винести однеєдине питання чи підтримуємо
ми дніпряни
свячеславці смертну кару для зрадників
України і сепаратистів таких як Віктор
Медведчук
так і ми шановні друзі хоча ми йдемо в
Європу рухаємось до більш гуманних
стандартів тим не менш Для нас це
принципове питання ми знаємо що якщо ми
сьогодні з вами не перейдемо в наступ
наш український наступ нас задушать як
задушили дончан і луганчан ми не дамо
нікому заткнути нам рота ми не дамо
нікому почуватися вільготно і спокійно в
серці України бо ми тут не на окупованій
Слава Богу покищо територія ми у себе
вдома в козацькому сячеславському краї
де формувались добровольчі батальйони де
тече Стрімка і гаряча українська кров і
ми обов'язково доведемо олійникам
бондаренкам коломойським і Зеленським Це
наша країна ми господарі в Україні
Український народ і ми обов'язково з
вами як це зробили на Майдані з
Януковичем реалізуємо статтю п'яту
Конституції України яка говорить що
єдиним носієм влади в Україні є народ і
він може здійснювати її
безпосередньо ми не допустимо в Дніпрі
того що відбулося в Донецьку і в
Луганську ми не допустимо в Дніпрі того
що зараз відбувається на вулицях Мінська
де здичевілий Кривавий кремлівський
диктатор проросійський Лукашенко знищує
тамтешній майдан у нас есть з вами і
досвід і сила і воля і ми з вами будемо
не тільки реагувати рефлексувати на
якісь там їхні ідеї про референдуми ми
будемо нав'язувати І впроваджувати
український порядок денний український
наступ ми на своїй
землі Ми українці і ми обов'язково
переможемо слава Україні
геро слава Слава нації
смертьга Україна
по вірю в Україну і вірю в кожного
[музика]
до нашої акції також доєднується депутат
Дніпровської міської ради співголова
громадської організації інститут людини
та міста експерт з розвитку міста Артем
[музика]
хмельников
дніпро-дніпропетровщина
Слава
Україні друзі чому ми сьогодні тут ми б
могли сьогодні бути серед своїх осель
свої серед своїх родин і насолоджуватися
нашим рідним містом нашою рідною країною
але є обставини які змусили нас сьогодні
бути тут і сказати своє рішуче ні ні тим
референдумам ні тим спробам почути і
відчути як ми на це реагуємо з боку
російських
колаборантів на сьогоднішній день ми
скажемо своє рішуче ні
тим хто
бажає розділяти Та
власткувати ми скажемо їм що ми сьогодні
зібралися І покажемо що ми єдині ми
єдина сила яка може об'єднатися
об'єднатися навколо справжніх патріотів
тому друзі я хочу вас закликати всіх
громадських діячів політичних діячів ми
маємо сьогодні об'єднуватись це має бути
лише одна мета в
кого Разом до перемоги Слава
[музика]
Україні
творчі люди дуже тонко відчувають оці
підводні рухи підземні рухи які для
замиленого ока може можуть бути
непомітними
і серед нас з нами є просто неймовірна
жінка яка має що вам сказати це відома
письменниця поетеса член Національної
спілки журналістів України активна
учасниця двох майданів Леся степовичка
ваші
[музика]
обласки
Добрий
вечір Добрий вечір січеславці Слава
[музика]
Україні неймовірний вечір і неймовірне
щастя бути сьогодні тут бути разом після
довгого тривалого карантину в центрі
пандемії яка знову другою хвилею
насувається нам на неї начхати нас
хотіли розсадити по квартирах закрити
нам рота А ми зібралися і нас знову
повний Майдан яке щастя що є в нас
європейська Солідарність яке щастя що
був у нас п'ятий президент і я вірю і ми
всі віримо що і сьомий буде президент
Петро Олексійович Порошенко Ми
віримо мене ніхто не просив говорити я
своїм серцем зараз говорю а тепер про
печальку про нашу про опзж і про їхній
референдум звідки беруться такі партії
секти такі старомодні ідеї які мучили
нашу Україну Ще 100 років тому оця ідея
референдуму ще 100 років тому
письменники творча інтелігенція України
в 20-ті роки минулого століття
роздумувала Яким шляхом піти Україні і
ви пам'ятаєте Микола Хвильовий який
видвинув висунув два лозунга два мотто
це було геть від Москви і дайш Європу 20
років тому давайте зараз разом скажемо
тричі геть від Москви геть від Москви
геть від Москви геть від Москви і чим
Дякую і чим це закінчилося це
закінчилося розстріляним
відродженнямся письменників і наш
валеріян Підмогильний з Дніпра загинули
на силовках Загублені отруєні знищені
невідомо де поховані і тут через через
100 років Новые Лица и страшно новые
идеи про русского брата оцей повзучий
сепаратизм оцей референдум я писала про
цю заразу коли починався в 13-му році
Євромайдан Я хочу нагадати їм партію
опзж про цю ззвучу заразу зараз зачитаю
цього
вірша на цій землі нам богом даній на
вічних берегах Дніпра ступаймо браття на
майдани Бо ім'я щастя і добра Європа
кличе приєднатись Та не пускають в рай
гріхи Верховна зрада хамська напасть
перекривають нам шляхи Дніпро і Львів і
Київ разом Ми подолаємо повзучу цю
заразу повстануть люди сче слава Героям
слава Україні
слава і тепер я ще хочу нагадати членам
опзж оцієї платформи вони Що забули що в
нас війна що Дніпро тут не може бути
такого референдуму тому щоні д це те
місто яке поставило стіну Путіну якби не
не Дніпро було б те що в Луганську в
Донецьку якби Дніпро не став тоді стіною
військові
обладміністрація наша всі герої зараз
вони і найбільше Хлопці ви знаєте що
найбільша кількість загиблих АТО - це
наші дніпропетровці і я хочу цим
повзучим сепаратистам які носяться з
своїм рефере
сказати що ми його тут не потерпимо він
нам не потрібний і хочу нагадати їм те
про що писавши нас Наш геній і наш
батько Тарас Григорович Шевченка про
москалів колись поет Євгеній євтушенку
написал такое стихотворение хотят ли
русские войны вы помните да и там так
получалось что и берьёвский и другие все
деревья типа Все так Нет не хотят не
хотят так оце моя відповідь
про те що у нас війна і вона не
закінчилась Чи хочуть москалі
війни спитайте ви у серани що налетіла
на наш край і Шевченків запалила
Рай Чи хочуть москалі війни спитайте ви
у сатани що сів на троні у Кремлі біду
приніс моїй
Землі де ви взялись зеленіо ловічки на
наші голови на наші кораблі на землі
наші предківські правічні і все що цвіло
й росло на цій
землі навіщо увійшли у нашу хату і
потоптали мальви у
дворі синів ховає Україна мати і сняться
кулемети
дітворі так ось який ти справді руський
мір так ось яка ти руска вісна
благословляє патріарх киріл і входить в
Україну
Сатана палають села і горить Донбас
стоїть москеля батальйон АТО
Ці хлопці леви кожен справжній АС з
такими не здолає нас ніхто Та тільки
бронік в них один на трьох на трьох
всього по
автомату зубами рвуть отой чортополог
відваги їм не
позичати тримайтеся синочки золотій
тримайтеся гвардійці оборонці Нехай вас
оминають кулі ті вертайтеся живими
добровольці програє демон скінчиться
війна повернем Крим і відбудуємо міста і
розцвітуть героїв імена Героям слава
Вічна слава ця Чи хочуть москалі
війни скоріше лихо про майни Чи хочуть
москалі війни Спаси нас Боже і
сохрани слава
Україні слава Слава нації
рода
Україна понад усе європейська
Солідарність понад усе
Порошенко понад усе Я вас люблю
ми
єдині бачите не просто так я говорив що
творчі люди тонко відчувають оці
підводні рухи які нам можуть бути
невидимі чи можуть здаватися нам
невидимими і Пані Леся сказала згадала
про репресованих яких вивозили до Сибіру
свого часу і то є дуже актуально тому що
на цю сцену Я запрошую керівника
обласного товариства політичних в'язнів
і репресованих будь ласка зустрічайте
Іван
дремлюга Доброго вечора шановні
свячеславці тут ли люди з усієї області
і ми дуже довго і ретельно йшли до того
щоб наша область називалася
січеславською ви пам'ятаєте які були
перепетії декілька років тому назад які
були проводилися акції на підтримку цієї
області і це дуже важливо щоб ми
продовжили цю тему тому що людина тільки
тоді має якісь життєві координати коли
вона коли вона
ідеологічно споріднена своїм
минулим У нас у місті Дніпрі є два
захоронення військ військових які
боролися за Україну це в парку на вулиці
на площі соворній заховано 14 наших
воїнів часів української народної
республіки і ось поруч є меморіальний
комплекс присвячений цим воїнам сучасним
в боротьбі за Росію тоді ми боролися з
москво
і тепер ми продовжуємо боротися з
московію але це не найголовніший ворог я
вам скажу тому що цей ворог відомий і ми
мобілізуємося на проти цього ворогу але
ворог сидить серед нас це руш мір це та
інфекція яка гішечи коронавірус вона нас
заполонила Я знаю що не всіх що тут дять
стоять а наш народ наших рідних вони до
сих пор живуть в Советском Союз А я я ме
того що голова Товариства Я ще очолюв
коміч реабілітацію і ми побачили істор
ких людей які були радянською владою
розкоркувані Е закаковані ні за що після
війни депортовані це десятки сотні тисяч
людей історія кожного це можнаписати
Тому нам дуже важливо
підтримувати єдність І вірити в Україну
ми Стараємося на тим питанням які
воювали за Україну наша Тепер задача цю
Україну відбудовувати і обороняти
обороняти від ворога зовнішнього і
внутрішнього і тому єднання для нас
надважливо Я думаю що ми будемо всі
об'єднутися в ім'я держави і ще одна
ремарка кожну націю ведуть провідники
провідник - Це надзвичайно важлива особа
за якою тягнеться люди
в нас має виникти своя українська еліта
і її провідники вони є вони народжуються
але люди повинні
вірити люди повинні
вірити тому що робиться а не тому що
кажеться в нас на жаль
дуже дуже дуже дуже ми поступили не так
як треба було поступити на минових
виборах ми обрали владу яка не
відповідає духау української нації вона
замінила наші пріоритети на зовсім інші
пріоритети і тепер ми повинні все
зробити для того щоб начали нашої країни
стали справжні пробтники які ведуть туди
куди нам потрібно Європа НАТО против
Росії Яка є нашим сподовничким ворогом
тому я сподіваюсь що вдая для насце сама
Головна наша задача Слава
Україні Слава Слава
нації
Україна знаєте друзі коли ми бачимо
нашого типу Верховного Верховного
головнокомандувача який не знає з якого
боку підійти до бронежилета який вважає
що армія - це щось типу чоловічого мис
кого клубу куди приходять мужики щоб
напитися ми робимо
так і єдине бажання яке прокидається Це
бажання провалитись від сорому
кліз але потім ми дивимось на свою армію
на свою справжню армію Ми дивимось на
тих хлопців і дівчат на чоловіків і
жінок які тримають над нами небо які
тримають отой Форпост який В окопах
у ми бачимо їхні очі ми бачимо їхні
серця і ми розуміємо що з ними ми не
прокладемо
і разом з ними ми не дамо коплюжити
честь і гідність тих кого з нами вже
немає
і ви дуже добре знаєте Можливо навіть і
краще як я
що зараз в Україні
є так дуже потужна 1 2 3 ми знаходимося
в
Дніпрі на акції європейської
солідарності Я зараз запрошую на ту
цену офіцера запасу збройних сил
України голову Дніпровської міської
організації європейська Солідарність
народного депутата України мого
скликання Тетяна
речкова
[музика]
Вітаю
дніпровщина Вітаю дніпровських
патріотів патріотизм - це здатність
єднатись з патріотами а не з
популістами і зараз тут люди які щиро
люблять свою
Україну які вірять її європейські
майбутня які захищали і захищають її
незалежність і першиму це відчули 2014
році
добровольце 2014 рік
дебальцева я привезла волонтерську
допомогу і один із
хлопців почав Вітаю колегу Так у нас тут
зараз дуже гущно бо акція триває кілька
тисяч людей зібралося у центрі Дніпра
із нами Разом пані Софія фдина і власне
хочу запитати як вам враження І які ваші
емоції викликає сьогоднішня патріотична
акція у Дніпрі ну Вітаю усіх з Дніпра Це
мій перший візит до цього міста і
насправді я є вражена вражена тим що ми
дуже багато чули що Дніпро - це
бендерштат на Дніпрі що тут справжні
патріоти але сьогодні ти маєв можливість
їх безпосередньо всіх бачити тих людей
які з 14го року тримають оборону хтось
волонтеркою хтось позицією хтось службою
на на державних посадах але в будь-якому
випадку це є різні люди з різних
середовищ для яких Україна залишається
понад усе і для них не існує України
какеє разніце чи та сторона це люди які
готові переступати через внутрішні певні
свої якісь розбіжності а можливо сварки
але які точно знають що сьогодні такий
самий бій як в 14-му А можливо і більший
має бути тому ко тому що коли тебе
переконують що все зрада все опускаються
руки Все не так все не то і нужна міра
мір Ти розумієш що підходить знову ж
таки до визначення чи агресор нас доб'є
чи ми все-таки втримуємо свою українську
державу і це є насолода на іншій на
іншій кінці мапи мапи України бачите
стільки жовто-блакитних прапорів бачите
таких неймовірних людей які з'їхалися з
різних міст дніпровщини але також з
різних східних областей і я направду
щиро тшуся що це все моя Україна бо моя
Україна - це не тільки Львів моя Україна
- це не тільки Київ Де я зараз працюю
моя Україна - це там де є українці і це
надзвичайно Скажіть будь ласка власне
людей сколихнуло те що опозиційна
платформа за життя з бордів закликала
провести референдум що ви можете коротко
нам будь ласка сказати з цього приводу
по-перше такі партії як ця конкретно з
конкретної позиції вони взагалі мали би
бути з 14-го року заборонені у нашій
державі те що на жаль зараз так багато
людей віддає їм свою підтримку це є
насправді єрець другий момент з
референдумів денери ленери і Криму
почалася окупація України і почалися
масові вбивства Я сьогодні була в музеї
АТО вашому абсолютно неймовірному
Дніпровському музею АТО це історія
величезної жертви це історія величезних
втрат це історія величезної праці і я не
вірю що люди які це все здійснили які
тут по суті сталиор захисту України
проти Московського агресора настільки
легко можуть здавати сьогодні Україну Я
не знаю що трапилось Я не знаю що мусить
трапитися але в будь-якому випадку
будь-який такий Референдум це плювок в
очі і в пам'ять кожному нашому герою
будь-які такі референдуми - це розкачка
стабільності держави і референдуми
потрібні не Україні в нас все просто ми
свій референдум відбули в 91му коли
визначили що Україна має бути а оте що
зараз пропонується
Це нам пропонується нашими власними
руками визнати що наш бій був марним я
не вважаю що це можливо я вірю що це
неможливо в Дніпрі дякую вам дуже
нагадаю ми мали можливість
поспілкуватися із народним депутатом
України Софією фединою акція ж
продовжується і прямий залишається в
прямому ефірі колего передаю тобі
словоже
бага мене зву
повіктор я ветеран російсько-української
війни я доброволець першої свої
мобілізації 2014 року Коли я прийшов в
93 бригаду я був шокований
станом бо за 20 років
4го коли я звільнився зі стокової служби
Українській армії нічого не
змінилося хіба що техніка застаріла на
20 років почала
щеішроматися в травні коли Ми
знаходились вже зоні АТО ми голосували
на президентських виборах і Я жодного
разу не
постудував за свій
вибір через місяць в
червні нам на наші бойові позиції
привезли протижеле
їна вдумайтесь вцього цей місяць Петро
Порошенко домовився з нашими
європейськими
партнерами і за програмою допомоги
Україні нелетальною
зброєю спромівся поставити на позиції
націівкі
броноле А коли ми повернулися по нотації
в Восени
14го ми отримали
канадські версії канадсько
форми почалася реформа армії
реформувалася система
харчування Ми почали випуск своєї форми
і своїх власних верців
ми
відновили виробництво боєприпасів для
свольної артилерії великих Калін
ми розробили
і
успішно
випробували ракетні системи вілька і
Нептун і у нас був дух
Перемоги дивно звучить Але у нас
почалася українізація України
що ми маємо
зараз зараз у нас зупинилася інтеграція
в Європейський союз у нас зупинилася
інтеграція в НАТО Ми відступаємо з
власних обласоних позицій хоча на це
немає жодних підстав в нас жодного дня
обстрілів у нас жодного дня ра у нас
кожного дня
трах в мене немає слів щоб
висловити відношення до ситуації в
Україні в триконтактну групу його
контактну групу призначаю старого діда з
явниками з явними ознаками
деменції і
мараз який здав нашу зброю ядер
підписавши меморандум який не можна
використати навіть туалетний папір тому
Я закликаю всіх небайдужих патріотичних
і свідомих громадян Тім Хто знаходиться
тут іхто мене Можливо бачи бачить на
своїх
екранах Я закликаю вас проголосувати на
місцевих виборах за єдину політичну силу
яка довела за пть років що може успішно
боротися з
агресією з
окупацією з зовнішнім ворогом і яка буде
боротися з ворогом внутрішні з тими
посіпаками які пропонують нам свої
наративи свої моковиські ідеї якихстам
референду Слава
українілава учасник
російсько-української війни викладач
представник громадської організації
справа громад член ради територіальної
організації європейської солідарності
Дмитро
[музика]
кошка Вітаю всі Свою промову Я хотів би
почати з фрази розумні вчаться на чужих
помилках а дурні на
свої згадайте скільки разів ми вже
втрачали
нашу країну коли вона навіть зникала і
світових
ма візьмемо хоча б період визвальних
змагань коли за пять років змінилось
чотири режима і по ітогу Україна
опинилася під окупаченя чому таке
трапляється тому що найлегше критикувати
тих хто порить з вами Хто стаїть з вами
в Клічко кого Ви добре знаєте І знаєте
кожен його недоліку кожну зможку
і під
час того як ми критикуємо свої побративі
ми нерідко відвертаємось від ворогів і
забуваємо що таке справжнє зло а в
результаті всілякі там товарщі білкули
виявляються разом новими обличчями котрі
ніколи не були в політиці і це цитата із
справжнього живого студента дета котрою
я почув в
університеті Справа в тому що студенти
тоді вони були ще школярами вони не
цікавилися політикою вони не знають що
партія регіоні хто її представляв і що
вони закликали сюди руський мір Можливо
тому пан Кучма пан кін зараз виглядають
як доволі такі нові обличчя нормально
прокатуються ткг і знаючи як у нас вчать
історію я не здивуюсь якщо і пан
грушевськийм у вас є контакт попередати
можна через ма можна через та Зайдіть
[музика]
в передайте їй чи чи Зайдіть в наш офіс
і передайте мені конверта скажіть щоб
зустрічалися сячеславська 39
через будь-кого передавай Я з усіма
усторо буду зчати
знають історію А пан Грушевський пан
інниченко скарапатський теюра Це дуже
гарні приклади приклади того як не має
бути Приклади того до чого ми не маємо
допустити ні в якому
разі тому закликаю вас Давайте вже
вчитись на чужих помилках
неворюва все все нормально не хвилюйтеся
ви дочекалися Слава
Україні запрошую до слова керівника
секретаріату обласної організації
європейської солідарності Сергія
проценка привіт порохобрати і
порохосестри друзі Я знаю що сьогодні
тут на плоі ні всі хто точно розуміє що
написано на тих обзжшних бордах точно
розуміє що вони хотіли сказати О цим
крапках
референдуму я точно знаю що всі ті хто
зараз тут присутні і кого зараз немає бо
зміг доїхати Точно вони знають що ми не
дамо їм повернути 14-й
рік Дякую
друзі я хочу сказати що нас чекає ще
одна подія восени 25 жовтня ми з вами
разом повинні перемогти і без вас без
об'єднання всіх патріотичних сил ми це
зробити не зможемо тому друзі Я хочу
всіх закликати до лав європейської
солідарності Приходьте до наших офісів
приходьте до наших наметів Приходьте або
через інтернет реєструйтесь Приходьте до
нас і висловлюйте свою патріотичну думку
бо разом з вами ми зможемо перемогти і
опзж і цю ну сказали нельзя але це
зелену владу можна так сказати і ми
разом з вами можемо зробити Дніпро і
дніпропетровщину сильнішу слава
українілава
[музика]
бра зараз слово до вас має
журналістка волонтерка активістка
європейської солідарності Марина
[музика]
Соломко Вітаю всіх шановне
панство Я хочу нагадати вам сьогодні про
те що Україна
знову народилися у 2013
році саме
тоді на світ з'явилася єдина і сильна
українська
нація але вже понад рік у мене відчуття
паралельної
реальності знову кожна Незгода кожен
косий погляд розцінюється як пряма
загроза для царя та
боярі всі ми з вами пам'ятаємо
2013-14 роки коли лишень за синью-жовту
стрічку на одязі чи за Українську мову
ми з вами наражалися на
небезпеку у мене часто запитують звідки
я чому я говорю українською Я відповідаю
завжди Я з Дніпра і це правда Я
народилася і виросла у Дніпрі проте
повсякчас почала спілкуватися українську
з 2006
року і ви знаєте таке відчуття
складалося спершу коли Я перейшла з дому
на вання в громадських місцях ніби я
якийсь Прибулець у власній країні тому
що навколо мене лунало переважно
російська
мова проте ситуація починаючи з 2013
року кардинально
змінилась ми з вами зрозуміли що окрім
речей які
нас
роз'єднують якими ми
відрізняємося є значно важливіші речі
які нас
об'єднують і відтоді українська мова
дедалі частіше лунає на вулицях
українських міст українська стала нормою
а не винятком і у
Дніпрі А це означає
друзі що ми з вами стаємо
сильнішими
витривалішими у протистоянні зовнішнім
ворогам ви знаєте я за останні сть років
надзвичайно стала пишатися розвитком
української
культури Наше Кіно музика
мистецтво не лишень отримують міжнародне
визнання вони ще і посідають чільне
місце зараз в нашій
країні проте цього року прикриваючись
боротьбою з коронавірусом заслуги
вирішили скоротити фінансування
культурної галузі але знаєте це і не
дивно адже культура закінчується там де
починається 95-й квартал Я думаю
так І знаєте
друзі Важливо не лишень те що за останні
сть років українська нація почала
відроджуватися а і те що українці
позбулися комплексу
меншеовартості стали сильними вільни ми
і згуртованими як ніколи І саме за це
Сьогодні намагатимуться судити кожного з
нас проте російські Посіпаки забувають
що українці давно вже не раби і
200414 роки довели що ми можемо забувати
січвари і об'єднуватися заради спільної
мети демократичного майбутнього нашої
країни Ми не злякалися тоді Тим паче ми
не злякаємося і зараз за тож гуртуємося
друзі восени зелене листя неодмінно
пожовкне і
опаде місцеві громади мають можливість
зітхнути з полегшенням якщо зроблять
правильний вибір Дякую Слава Україні
[музика]
що ж
товариству сьогодні було дуже багато
сказано сьогодні
пролунали і речі які ви вже чули і ті
які чули
вперше тим не менш
сьогоднішня патріотична акція в Дніпрі
Українці єднаємося це
є отой правильний
маркер яким ми говоримо про російським
найманцям Хлопці ви не тою дорогою
йдете
ми знаємо що правда Буде за
нами тому що з нами бог і Україна з нами
правда А якщо з нами Бог То хто проти
нас якщо з нами Бог То хто проти нас алу
не сміє бути в нас страху ні жодної
застроги тому що миє
лицарі і ми є лицарі отої справжньої
залізної остроги залізного фрпосту і
товариство Я хочу попросити вас підійти
максимально близько до сцени ми зараз
так розпорошились трошки розійшлися будь
ласка підійдіть трошки ближче тому що
зараз буде така своєрідна промова мені
надзвичайно приємно оголошувати цих
хлопців на
сцені попри Хай свій молодий вік всього
8і років Я не побоюсь цього слова вони
стали вже динозаврами
української сцени вони стали отими
лісовими чортами які вискочили і сказали
українська музика є Які поїхали по
всьому світу і всюди сказали що
українська музика є що українська музика
- це не галімий Патап який турси знімає
Чи штани знімає перед ворогом А є якісна
українська музика яка живе і буде жити
поки є цих хлопці з превеликою радістю
на сцені нашої акції Дніпро для вас
козак
[оплески]
[музика]
сист Добрий
вечір Добрий вечір
[музика]
[оплески]
Дніпро Ну сьогодні для нас
дуже цікавий день тому що Тут недалеко в
кав'ярні Ми обідали зустріли одного із
культових патріотів ее дніпрянщини ашара
черкаського Нашого друга ви знаєте його
Хто не знає загугліть поцікавтесь
зустріли Дмитра Яроша посиділи
поспілкувались
що я вам хочу сказати вчора в мене був
День народження
вітаю і пізно вечері до мене подзвонило
два президента це для мене було дуже
зворушливо тому що я ну я намагаюсь жити
дуже
скромно так
що але так чи інакше подзвонив не
Зеленський і не подзвонив Кучма і не
подзвонив Кравчук як ви розумієте а
подзвонило два українських президенти і
Кожен з них сказав не знаючи що вони
будуть зі мною розмовляти Вони сказали
майже одне і те ж вони сказали козаки
Іванку я вам бажаю
натхнення на тій дорозі по якій ви
йдете для того щоби наша українська
Україна була
українською це дуже зворушливо ми тут
для того щоби будь-які
спроби нав'язати нам чужу культуру чуже
мистецтво чуже мислення
присікалося нас чекають попереду вибори
і ви знаєте що в цій країні вибори дуже
багато значать тому що від кожного із
вас кожен
голос формує ваше майбутнє сучасні
технології дуже небезпеч нас задурюють
нас обманюють нам
показують якісь такі фокуси де ми
можемо зійти з нашого шляху Будьте
пильними пам'ятайте
будь-хто хто декларує
якісь цінності які не притамані
українцям руський Мир там референдуми і
все решту відганяйте це від себе як
чортівню будь
пильними будьте хазяєвами своєї долі з
вами сьогодні козак систн Добрий
[музика]
вечір
запозичені
речення з книжок та фільмів ми вживати
приречені Ми ненадто вільні ідучи на
побачення розсипаючись іскми раптом
знайдемо
значення маленької
істини
Мій друг нам з
тобою зможе світить сонце ранньою
весною нам з тобою мій
[музика]
друг зрі вкажу шлях у семи
морях задивляючись в дзеркало рахуємо
втрачене між цирком і
церквою Ниці не пчимо там наведені хаосу
і блуканні
світами раптом робимо паузу подзвонити
до мами
Мій друг нам з
тобою знов за світить сонце ранньою
весною нам з тобою мій
друг зрі вкажу шлях у зми морях
[музика]
гей понад хмадами
гронами сходить сонце
розпечене образ стають
законами запозичені
речі кожен склачує митоло хто столух до
престолу може варто спинитись
озирнувшись довкола
Мій друг нам з
тобою знов засвітить сонце ранньою
весною нам з тобою мій
друг зрі вкажу шлях Я у земи морях
Мій друг нам з
[музика]
тобою знов засвітить сонце ранньою
весною нам з тобою мій
труг зі вкажуть
шлях у сими
морях запозичені
речення з книжок та фільмів
ми вживати приреченні
ми не надто вільні ідучи на
побачення розсипаючись іскрами раптом
знайдемо
значенні
маленької
[музика]
істини
дякуємо
постукали в
двері з ранковим дощем
рва
скопила
[музика]
тримає я б їй
написала споличиві
поеми та я її зовсім не знаю
ні міста її щоденни добрі і друзі вні
Рідко я взяв їю руку Якби
тільки приклав до серця до
свого у озері очі твої
і я закохавсь і тебене була зараз
Ти
уложені очі твої
мій світ
обвірваввсь улосні очі
твої Я б не
питав в неї з ким вона
спить по кому квітки
і
сохнув як слухав І з
нею як лемше вести як жовні садки мертво
мокнуть не знаю ні вулиць ні таж ні
адрес ні розмірів ніх ні героїв
Ні вірші улюблених ні поете ічо Та все ж
я з
тобою у осені очі
твої Я завався і теб не бував
заразти уласні очі твої
СС у осені очі
твої
[музика]
і поки не
знаю тривається ра Він мій інтерес
ривеся
[музика]
далі спокусливо
хвора осіння
гора
полю душі і
медалі
посухав двері з ранковим дощем
іластупила
Тримай я б ї написа в 100 віршів і
поем я її зовсім не
знаю у осені очі
твої Я
запокався і тем не влаце
рости у осені очі твої
мі
свірвався
усиночі твої
у осені начі
твої і
я іте не
була осені очі твої
мі
слась осні
[музика]
очілі
Дякуємо я знаю точно що цю країну врятує
класна якісна душевна професійна
українська музика чоловікам не варто
знати про наслідки їм достатньо причин
коли вони отримують все вони наповнюють
його нічим коли вони говорять про
спільне Вони мають на увазі своє з ними
краще не говорити про те що
буде
поливова знову де сюди Коли
вона коли вона знову знає Не мене ші
тоючи лише одне те що було навнону
щоб буде теж мене тому не ховай свого
лиця ти що немає початку кінця доки
звівається наша ніжність покилються наші
серця наші
серця
наші
серця наші
серця наш
[музика]
[оплески]
серця дякую
дніфро
отут збоку стоїть наш автобус Ми на
ньому приїхали вийшли а поруч сидить
пара красивих людей хлопчик дівчинка і в
неї випадково задзвонив
телефон на
рингтоні стоїть пісня яку ми зараз з вам
заграємо це так зворушливо Це дійсно
дуже зворушливо коли ти робиш для людей
і воно відгукується ва наших душах коли
на жаль уже покійний Поет Василь
Симоненко який робив геніальну поезію
який як і ми хотів бачити
Україну вільною незалежною справжньою
українською Якби він почув цей рінгтон
думаю там на небі йому було б Легше Я не
знаю що там але я знаю що тут і тут у
нас Україна
не
моя
на наша Земля наші правила
[музика]
пацани Ну скажи хіба не стични що у
цьому хаосі доріг
під сувоним небом небом вічним я тебе
зустрію і не сбеі ти і я це вічне як і
небо доки мерехтітимуть світи будуть я
Приходити до тебе і до інших тимуть
горді ти Як все буденно Як все звиш
скільки раз це бачила
земля Але ми з тобою ми не вічніні ми з
тобою просто ти я як будинно як все
звично скільки раз це бачила
земля Але ми з тобою ми не вічні ми з
тобою просто ти і
я
[музика]
Ну скажи хіба це не печально що життя
без гриму і прикрас розкидало штормом
п'ятибайним наші сни так само як і в нас
доля часто є
несправедлива там і туть так само як і
скрізь як сь буду я ти бу щаслива А з
тобою вільще не зійтись Як все будено Як
все звічно скільки раз це бачила земля
але ось з тобою ми не вічніми зстобоми
просто ти я як тенно як все
звично скільки раз тачила
земля Але ми з тобою ми Не вчи не з
тобою просто ти і
[музика]
я
Як все будено Як це
звично скільки раз цебачила
земля Але ми з тобою Ми неічні не з
тобою просто ти я як
Но як все звично скільки раз бачила
земля але з тобоюми не вічні не з тобою
просто
і тому для мене tak трагчно те що ти
чияся не моя і тому для мене так
трагічно те що ти чиєся не моя і тому
для мене так трагічно
те що ти чиєся не моє і тому для мене
так
трагічно що ти
[музика]
чиясть а не
моя Дякуємо дорогі тут
свят ведучий сьогоднішнього нашого
концерту І вокаліст гурту широкілан вам
дуже добре порадив підтягуйтесь ближче
до нас Ей там
позаду не сидіть в піцерії в піцерії
завтра посидите Ідіть сюди до нас
Давайте давайте
кучкуємося тут кращий звук тут видно
наші обличчя і видно ваші обличчя
ее Ну я думаю що кожен із вас нарешті
вже пережив цей важкий період під назвою
карантин
і ми з козаками під час цього карантину
те що називається не сиділи склавши руки
не біткались а збирались на репетиційній
базі і
написали Уявіть собі написали дев'ять
нових пісень які з 1 вересня начнамо
записувати як новий альбом козак System
А сьогодні ми вам презентуємо дві нові
пісні вони сьогодні будуть звучати
вперше і це пісні з нового альбому
позаксист
[музика]
журавлі зазирни під мою
шкілу там ленемо
жураблі там ще не вигадали
Віру і море повне
[музика]
кораблі там ріки тихі повновотні
дую землю Новаком
що ти побачила
сьогодні за с
лиміком тво моє серце мою душу мої мрі
мої сни Хто як не ти те мене нате мене
таємними світами
ях не ти заце сіє моє небо синє небож
[музика]
правлями я сам у руки твої
лесо якщо захочеш
покладу бо я від тебе не
тверези та все одно до тебе йду
Я майже Віру твого
тіла прийняв за істину
собіпере усе чило
хотіла я віддаю лише тобі
і моє серце мою душу мої мрії мо
їсни Хто як не ти
де менеде мене таємними світами
янети засіє моє небо синє небо
[музика]
журавлями
моє серце мою душ мой мрі
мої смі то якк не ти Веде мене веде мене
таємними
світами
Хто як не ти засіє моє небо сіє небо
[музика]
шуреблями О я
крети Веде мене вете мене приємними
світами бо як лети за сіє моми немебо
синє немебо жуда
Веда
хто
[музика]
[оплески]
яклети Дякую нам Як ви бачите самим
подобається грати нові пісні бо нове це
завжди нове наступна пісня називається
Wind and
Fire Я так розумію що Ця абревіатура або
сполучення слів для вас не дуже відоме
ви загугліть А ми вам Зараз скажемо що
and fireire - це культова група Америки
яка колись в свій час стала
розначальником цілого стилю там симфофн
або там джазфн або ну неважно для вас це
якісь чужі слова але так чи інакше Це
була культова група тих то тієї молоді
Яка пізніше
формувала сучасне мислення Америки і ми
написали пісню яка
називаєтьсяn and
Fire
[музика]
ти ти мене
прости за те що я я був не
тим не тим хто
переверне світ зніг на
молову
а Але ти ти мене
прости за
нічні
пости і
залисти що були
пусті ти
мене
прости лети
лети не
забувай намебі точно знаю чи я тебе
кохаю
[музика]
нам знову заграє ажві набає ажмі
набає все все би я
віддав за те що в час належив Нам щоб
нам нагадали ЗНО про щирі с
нанших різних мов Але ти ти мене про
сти за
нічні
пости за листи що були
густі ти
мене
прости лети
лети не
забувай на небі точно знаю Я тебе кохаю
і нам знов
Заграй
[музика]
а лети
лети не
забувай на небі точно знаю чи я тебе
кохаю нам
[музика]
заєєє
де ваші
рукип гоп
[музика]
тилети не
забувай на небі точно знаю
Я тебе
кохаю знов зарає а свіне пає а свіне пає
лети
лети не
забувай на небі точно знаю я
[музика]
тебехаю
сонцеграє ажти
[музика]
наєєєє
[оплески]
Ну що вам сподобались нові
пісні Дякую Я сподіваюсь що ми з вами
Побачимося в нашому турі А ми з козаками
плануємо тур з новим альбомом і ми
обов'язково приїдемо в Дніпро до вас ви
прийдете до нас на
[музика]
концерт
щому
дочі занадто багато слів не тримай Не
питай не
плач амго
флащі у бруді з чужих коліс не трима
не стай
прова я забв твої Колею боїх не співай в
день
усміхнувшись в обли зливі сказала досить
сумних
[музика]
пісень
ісень доси соних пісень
фрми доси соних
[музика]
пісень самотнім
дощем шукає мотив
твій де ти є Де ти Де
ти Подай мені ще
єдино зіста на Ді зачаруй закохай
пусти я дістану музику з неба слова із
пустих
кишень буду чекати коли ти скажеш
міям досить сумних
пісень досить сумних
пісень досить сумнихпінь
[музика]
сить сумних
піецьго всього ми
ви досить сумних пісень Я маю повірити
просто скажи
мені ісень ще ще голосні все
простое просто залишити тугу без
мені цього
[музика]
всього Я маю повірити просто скажи
мені ти
вжела все
про і дуже-дуже голосно всі
[музика]
разо досить сумних пісень
ших сумних пісень
[музика]
носить сумних
пісеньсить сумних
пісень А тепер Дніпр ми перевіримо чи ви
запам'ятали слова
оп дніпряни счеславці дорогі Ви готові з
нами співати
[музика]
готові просто дость сумних пісень
запам'ятали не
чую пісень І
раз
дтч всього ми випили
достальте Я маю повірити просто скажи
[оплески]
мені бо ти вже навчила як вже все
просто
просто залишити ту без івенігагами
[музика]
били
достачи Я маю повірити просто скажи
мені бо ти вже навчила як же все
[музика]
просто просто залишити
дуні сумих
пісень
[музика]
Кай дякуємо
вам
[музика]
супер давайте радіти життю друзі
нам цей Путін 100
[музика]
роківля він все одно стохне а нам жити і
радіти
все починається ніч розчиняється зорі
ховається день розрдняється ти
прокидаєшся і посміхаєшся А я тебе цілую
і вітаю з добрим ранком мило Все
починається люди встрічаються хтось
закохається хтось попрощається всяке
трапляється життя насняють а я тебе
цілую ми щастиві разом титика як
літо а тити Та
куди мені
подіти що
[музика]
менецеітити ати
ди поніти
ле
[музика]
ла-ла-ла-ла-ла-ла все починається весна
розягається теплими зливам знову
вмиваюсь ти прокидаюсь і посміхаюсь Я
тебе цілую і вітаю з добрим ранкоммилос
починаються люди встрічаються хтось
закохається хтось попрощається всяки
трапляється життя не споняється А я тебе
цілую ми щасливі назти такає
бліко а ти тате
димені
поічи щоіти
вічи а тика я
іко а тикає
іко куди мені подіти
що меніцеітицеіти
[музика]
майже майже майже майже
А ти тикає
Ліко А ти тикає
і куди мені
подітиітити
а
куди мені
[музика]
[оплески]
подіти
[музика]
п п ручки ручки Гоп гоп гоп п п п п п п
п п п п п п
[музика]
ппппппп дорога на
проста мій телевізор небо в горі інки на
ньому не мовні Старі А за вікномце нові
міста я так збираюсь жити
[музика]
достатково
enger і кілометрий
рай живу як аше тепер і тут бо невідомо
майбутні маршрут я
[музика]
посхаюeng
La
[музика]
рушки руки рушки
стрибаю у мій
фургон давай Бебі
Кан і хоч дороги розбиті вще нехай їх
зовсім змиє доще нам з тобою за
небокрай давай Бебі
[музика]
[оплески]
Дякуємо Дніпро Дякуємо дорогі друзі Ми
раді були бачити вас сьогодні і
сподіваюсь ми не одноразово Ще
побачимося тут в Дніпрі на концертах
козаксисти А взагалі будьте свідомими
робіть правильні висновки тому що з вами
сьогодні козак
систн достойно достойно проважаємо
хлопців наших козаків які знають що таке
українська музика і які якісно її грають
дніпряни Вам
сподобалось і в мене для вас є ще один
такий маленький маленький
сюрприз як Фінальний акорд цієї акції
нашої Української акції в Дніпрі Я зараз
на цю на цю сцену на завершення нашої
акції запрошу одну прекрасну
дівчину яка народи
просто прекрасний мем в Україні під
назвою
потерпілий ви знаєте про кого йде мова
[музика]
так тож будь ласка
градоначальниця мему потерпілий а
насправді дуже активна волонтерка
Прекрасна людина народний депутат
України Софія
Федина
[музика]
Слава Україні с
слава Ось тут Ліворуч від мене два
неймовірних
кольори мій український
прапор в якому Зливається і синь небес і
золоте
колосся яким промовляє Сонце над моєю
державою
за цей
прапор пролито немало
крові найпаскудніше що пролито крові
немало
зараз коли у нас є наша українська
держава проте занадто багато кому вона
не
подобається занадто багато кому печуть
як свята вода для чорта оце блакить і
цей золотий сонячний
колір коли чорта кроплять свяченною
водою воно
шкварчить воно
викручується воно намагається зробити
якомога більше шкоди але чим більше
святої води тим більше нечисті
згине тому наше завдання
піднімати наш прапор так високо як можна
і саме з цим прапором переможним
українським стягом іти в
бій
сьогодні я мала честь вперше бути в
музеї АТО тут у
Дніпрі У нас у Львові чомусь такого
немає а у вас
тут я відчула ось те
справжнє чого я постійно відчуваю коли
їду на
передову бо кадри з музею і
експонати всі ці хроніки мені нагадали
Найважливіші речі які відчуваєш там на
війні війна принесла багато болю
страждань і
втрат але я буду дякувати за цю
війну бо війна
показала Хто за Україну
А хто
проти війна показала Хто друг а хто
ворог війна показала де правда і де
кривда І так сьогодні там на передовій
нам волонтером
простіше бо ти відкидаєш в сторону усі
нюанси і точно знаєш що ти в цей
конкретний момент маєш
робити і там на лінії зіткнення сьогодні
там де наші Захисники
Ти розумієш що немає Какая
разница А є
Україна немає та сторона А є ворог і
вбивця Московська
Федерація не має домовлятися кдето
посередині бо є зараза яка прийшла на
нашу землю вбиває на
людей і приносить втрати і війну на нашу
землю і миру не буде
доти доки Ми цю заразу не випечемо і не
витравимо свяченою водою нашого прапора
і нашої віри із нашої
землі Я сьогодні хочу
дякувати дякувати
щиро
Дніпро за те що він направду є тим
містом як у нас кажуть у Львові Дніпро -
це Бандерштат на
Дніпрі це є Форпост української
боротьби я дякую Дніпру що ви тут
зупинили Московську навалу
що ви стали отою гранітною стіною яка не
дала перети Московській орді
далі я доземну склоняюся кожному
волонтеру і кожному
захиснику тому що від маленького
кроку від маленького
рішення від маленької справи залежало чи
Україна буде чи її не буде сьогодні моя
Україна
є сьогодні наша Україна є і щоб
остаточно витравити ворога із нашої
землі нам потрібно кілька речей
перше це
єдність тому що занадто багато у нас є
ворогів але чомусь сваримося ми між
собою і ворог від цього виграє
ухвиляється і насміхається над нами наша
єдність - це запорука нашої сили але
щоби була
сила нам потрібна наша правда і треба
все називати своїми імена нами і треба
казати на Чорне
-чорне на біле- біле На ворога- ворог А
на побратима побратим і разом плече до
плеча рука до руки тримати свій бій і
нам потрібна
щирість бо без щирого
серця без світлих помислів і без щирої
любові до
України нічого доброго не буде але ця
щирість є І знаєте Я щойно повернулася з
Луганщини і
Донеччини Я ще раз знаю що у нас іде
трансляція знаю що багато хто
стрімить я хочу подякувати усім нашим
захисникам Подякувати І сказати що що би
там хто з ким десь понятним не
домовлявся цю
армію створив український
народ якщо хтось посягає на наше
військо то українському народу не
заборониш тримати оборону а це означає
що ми станемо поруч зі своїми
захисниками і як буде потреба дамо бій і
як буде потреба підемо до кінця правда
Як в нас на Майдані казали не до кінця а
обов'язково до української Перемоги
Слава
Україні Слава і ви знаєте завершити Я
хочу дуже особливою піснею
піснею яка вродилася в процесі
волонтерської діяльності
пісні яка
вродилася з огляду на оборону
луганського
аеропорта однієї з перших подій з якої
все
почалося але пісня про те
що Самі знаєте особливо волонтери і
Захисники знають що коли особливо
паскудно і опускаються руки раптово
стається
щось що дозволяє
вижити раптово стається щось що змінює
хід подій раптово куля снайпера застрє в
Біблії коло
серця а це означає що з нами бог Бог а
якщо з нами Бог То хто ж проти нас якщо
з нами Бог то перемога обов'язково Буде
за нами музику будь
ласка присвято усім хто з нами усім хто
сьогодні на
небі тим хто сьогодні боженьку молить
про нашу перемогу і про благословіння
для України а я хотіла би побачити зараз
угорі мобільні телефони включіть
ліхтарики хай ми хоч трошечки просвітимо
тут темряву яка навколо
нас Світанок Над полем боє і ми братку з
тобою
цю ніч
пережили і сонце зустріли
щоночі всі кола пекла
Ми дивимось в очі смерті коли вжеве
сила не видима
сила дарує нам
крила
звершити свіі з нами Бог і в нас одна
дорога здобути
перемогу і виграти цей дій з нами
країну не
здолати бо ми її
солдати бороним нарід свій бороним нарід
свій
пекельно-квіткове поле
засіяне кров'ю й болем Та ми не
втомились ми не втомились живими лиш
шились
чудований ангол смерті де ж взялись такі
ви вперті постали з
бетону обрнулись з полону і з Богом за
руку
бороним свій рай з нами Бог і в нас одна
дорога здобути беперере могу і виграти
цей бій з нами
Бог країну
назвати бо ми її
солдати пороним нарід свій борони нарід
свій Я
вірю що скоро війна має
закінчитися але закінчуватися вона може
тіки на
перемогою коли ми Московську рду
викинемо з нашої землі і пімстимо смерть
великих лизаерів а тоді всі зможемо
повернутися додому і просто жити в своїй
Україні і коли тобі важко йти вперед І
коли ти не можеш зробити крок
хтосьравдово підстави тобі плаче споя
Бог
з нами Бог і в нас одна
дорога збти
перемогу і виграти цей бій з нами
дг країну не
столати абоми її
стовтати короним нарік
свій боронить нарік
свій
[музика]
[оплески]
не
вмерла
України і
славані воля
Ще нам
браття
українці
усміхнеться до
ля
Згинуть наші
воріженьки як
роса на
сонці
[музика]
запануєми браття у свої
состороці Душу й тіло ми
положим за нашу
[музика]
свободуду і
покажем що ми
браття
козацького
роду
душу тіла
ми
положим за нашу сво
воду і
покажем що ми
браття
[музика]
козацького
роду слава Україні гроям слава Слава
нації Смерть ворога Україна понад усе
полеглим героям України тричі слава
слава слава
що ж
дніпряни друзі
наші ми вам говоримо велике велике дякую
за вашу активність за вашу небайдужість
за ваші серця відкриті і щирі за ваші
душі і за ваші Уми які розуміють що нам
потрібно як це нам потрібно І коли це
нам потрібно
Дякую за ваше
стремління До чистої України до
української України яка омріяна і
оспівана багатьма поетами багатьма
музикантами громадськими мистецькими
політичними діячами і кожним з
нас тільки разом ми її зможемо
побудувати тільки разом Тільки в єдності
Серце до серця плече до плеча рука до
руки разом твердим поступом Вперед і
тільки вперед Дніпро з вами Вся
Україна Ще раз Дякуємо Вам слава
Україні одна єдина Соборна Україна одна
єдина Соборна Україна одна єдина Соборна
Україна одна
єдина Соборна
[музика]
Україна ну і ми з вами не прощаємось Ми
не говоримо вам прощавайте ми говоримо
вам До зустрічі тому що ми обов'язково
ще з вами Побачимось Всього доброго з
Богом
[музика]
foreign